Whoa,
whoa.
You forgot where you were.
Yeah.
This is a,
this is the original spot.
And in the original spot,
uh,
now known as desk quad.
East east has cats and for some reason Brian has decided that squad west is a
primate based.
It's all the monkeys and scary thing to.
Right.
Well,
the studio itself definitely has a different feel.
You know,
with the Werewolf when you walk into the place that's this extraordinary
feelings.
Awesome.
It is awesome.
The coolest thing I've ever bought in my life.
Powerful Pat Mcgee,
guy from a pat mcgee special effects.
He makes them.
You can order one.
I didn't going to order one.
Before you got married,
your house would have at least seven
different when you live with the chicken man.
They start moving your shit around and putting pictures of your kids on the
wall.
And I used to have champs up all over my house.
If you went over to my house when I was a single mom,
not going to do.
I used to have pictures of champs everywhere in sculptures to weird sculptures
or weird shit.
Like literally you would walk around his whole entire house and there'd be a
monkey or a chimp every five steps or be a different picture.
Really eating a tiger or when chimps.
Eaton Tigers.
But I got them like how long chasing after.
How long were you rocking that though?
Oh Man.
I've been obsessed with chimpanzees since I was a baby.
So even like a teenager style you were doing?
Oh yeah.
I've always been obsessed with apes.
You just asked with them.
I find them fucking fascinating.
My,
my production company's name is talking monkey incorporate.
Yeah,
sure.
I got that was in like 1988 and that was a line I stole from a movie with um,
the fuck was that dude's name.
I forget his name.
Oh God.
Harman Mark Harmon thing.
That was his.
He had a funny movie,
like a summertime moving carmen.
Okay.
It was like summer school or some shit like that.
And I'm teaching summer school and he said to guy,
if you lose one more brain cell,
you'd be a talking monkey.
And I remember that all the sudden put in my head the idea of a talking Michael,
like how stupid would a person have to be if we really did evolve?
How far back would we have to go until we became a talking monkey,
you know,
what is that?
And so that became.
I mean,
it wasn't.
That was my initial obsession,
but that's why I named my company talking monkey in corporate.
I can see how an obsession with monkeys.
They're so fascinating,
man.
If they didn't exist,
we would be tripping the fuck out if we.
If someone showed you have newer no chimpanzees and all of a sudden we found
chimpanzee somewhere would be like,
holy shit.
Look at them.
They're looking at you.
They're thinking,
oh my God,
they using tools.
Holy Fuck.
Look at this.
This is like a window back in time.
This is like the fucking sensory deprivation tank and altered states.
We can see our past.
I mean,
you literally can see your past.
I mean somehow or another.
I don't understand that evolution scientifically,
behaviorally.
That wasn't.
When I talk like this.
People said,
well,
you really don't understand how evolution works.
Okay,
I appreciate that,
but I think you can reasonably extrapolate that if people exist,
and then there was some early people,
there was like no homo,
whatever.
It was like a bunch of different homos,
Homo ostrow,
Paleo,
osteopathic,
this thing Australia pivot that was a,
that one tube or direct ancestors that they believe.
It's like somehow or another we had to be like more primitive.
It wasn't like we just started out like,
like close to a human now.
There were some steps along the way you fuck.
Okay.
And I think it's not unreasonable to look at chimpanzees and say,
even though that's not our step along the way,
it's from a different branch of the same tree,
the same prime a tree.
I think you can reasonably extrapolate that there's something very similar to
the way they are that we probably were,
you know,
at least we can put it together.
Then in a rang of tanks and Bonobos,
we can mix them all together and try to figure out what the fuck we were like.
There's different models that have come along before humans can see class and
there was an easy class and then there's the s class.
You know what,
fuck,
fuck.
Commercials for this podcast.
I don't feel like doing any commercials.
This is like a podcast that came out of nowhere.
We didn't even see this coming.
Tommy buns.
We put it together last minute,
so no commercials.
Suck it,
suck it.
Please move on and let's just get going.
Brian Red Band,
work in the Mick Rock,
rocking the discs,
turning the tape
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Tommy Buns.
Now this podcast,
maybe the first podcast series ever plays.
Will you get the full podcast?
Seriously?
They don't have to edit that because we don't have a commercial in it.
Oh,
that's great.
So people don't know is that um,
I'm financially irresponsible and uh,
I,
I'm not that good at advertising shit.
Right?
And a lot of times when we do our podcast,
the advertisements may take as long as 20 minutes because somewhere in the
advertisements,
you know,
Brian,
callum might bring up some crazy fucking book that he read and all the sudden
we're on this wild journey or Duncan trussell blows your mind with a certain
thought in the middle of a commercial talking about something and now you're off
on a tangent path.
But a lot of that shit never makes it to Sirius satellite radio.
I even think isn't the show like an hour long to like they just edit it down to
an hour.
I don't know.
But it's awesome that they put us on there.
It's a,
I'm happy to be on there because it's opie and anthony or my friends and there's
a,
it's just,
it's a good group of humans,
you know?
They're good guys.
Jim Norton is a great guy.
I love being associated with those guys.
You know those,
those guys.
I'm down for them.
Everybody said my friend.
It seems like a good crew,
man.
They're great guys,
I,
Anthony's beautiful human being ops,
a fucking awesome guy.
Awesome.
Jim Norton is like one of my favorite humans ever,
you know,
so it's like all of them together.
We have some great conversations,
you know,
they're not dumb guys by any stretch of the imagination even though I disagree
with some of them ideologically,
like sometimes I disagree with Anthony.
He's real strong like right wing Republican,
but he's also,
I believe in a lot of things that he believes in.
There's a lot of shit that I believe in,
especially like the gun control issue,
you know?
I mean he's a bit extreme,
you know,
he's,
he's a crazy gun nut and he has guns.
But I honestly believe that when you see the shooting victims and all,
all these different things,
this is not a gun issue.
It's a mental health issue.
It's the ability to do that.
That should be so alien from our society.
And I liken it to a group of close friends.
Okay.
And this is obviously an exaggeration.
It's really hard to do when you're talking about giant society of people that
are never going to get to meet each other.
But in a group of close friends like us,
the people in this room,
okay,
let's pretend that we were all on a desert island.
What are the odds that one of us would become a suicide bomber?
Came pretty fucking small,
right?
It's pretty fucking small planes.
Does someone become a suicide bomber?
How does someone become a guide?
Would drop a bomb off at a marathon finishing line.
How does someone do that?
What?
What the fuck happens to that guy that lets you do that?
Because the reality is that there's a lot of shit that can kill people in this
world,
including cars and everyone has cars.
And if you want it to kill far more people than this guy did at the marathon,
you could run over people in your car.
The reason he did it this way is because he wanted to not be accountable for it.
He thought he could get away with it.
Sure.
If this is the,
you know,
if you buy the official story,
I'll Alex Jones.
Have you bought the official story?
Ladies and gentlemen?
But if you,
you know,
you look at this guy like who they're claiming this guy is,
that was the,
the,
the older brother,
they think he might've committed three murders as well.
Three murderers out there.
Yeah.
There was one night,
three people were murdered and one of them was a close friend and training
partner of this guy and the body's cash was left there and the bodies were
covered with marijuana.
Yeah.
And this guy was very religious apparently,
and become,
he'd become more and more religious in the past few years now again,
settled down tinfoil people.
This is,
if you buy the official story,
I don't know what the fuck this dude was,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm just reading what I'm getting out of.
You know,
essentially almost all news sources seem to be agreeing with,
with these stories that this guy was like super religious.
Well,
he went,
he got kind of radicalized that a couple of years ago.
He went back to to rush us for six months.
Say That's when he,
he came back and radicalize,
you know,
that's again,
that's the official story.
Jones will tell you it was a false flag event.
Tommy,
what they're doing it or trying to take away your guns were supposedly he
listened to Alex Jones.
He was a fan of infohort
when maybe he was a fan of infant wars.
The way I'm a fan of Sean Hannity,
like I'll listen just because it's fucking hilarity.
It's funny to watch people twist the narrative like that.
It's funny to watch people that are just so blatantly right wing that they'll
never admit anyone on the left has any idea.
It's always any even compliment is said with a smirk that soon to follow some
disparaging remark about who they are.
It's never like Obama's a brilliant man or even if it's even if it's an idea
that they were behind it,
there's still a spin on it,
so it's a.
it's a fucking game.
They're in a team and they strategize to get that team to win and they do it
within the rules,
but they know they're full of shit.
Like as they're doing it,
you can hear their voice.
They know they're full of Shit,
but the game is so screwy.
It's one of those games that doesn't make any sense like baseball.
Why the fuck do they dress like that?
Look how you're dressed.
Look at what those stupid fucking tights and what is that outfit?
What is that?
Those signs,
they've always dressed like that.
Goddammit.
They're stuck.
They're stuck with a stupid outfit back from when people didn't have newspapers.
That's when they made that dumb ass outfit.
That outfit's retarded.
It is.
It's ridiculous.
It's stupid as fuck.
It puts me in the tiers to watch that game
while it's fun.
Game to play.
But sure,
the butt getting stuck in that old shit like that.
That's the only reason why politicians are,
are able to get away with the way they communicate.
I can't.
I can't imagine being a person who is into politics like really into it and
like,
you know,
not be cynical and be like,
it's so disheartening to follow politics.
To me,
it just,
it absolutely kills the soul.
No one,
man.
I recognize it as.
I would kinda come an older man.
I recognize it for what it is.
It's an act.
Right?
You know,
and you know why I know because I do an act two,
I know what an act is like.
I know when I'm doing standup,
when I stand up,
I'm going to,
if you know,
if I want to do my best,
what I do is I ad libbed quite a bit,
but I also have some key components that I have broken down into pretty specific
ways of saying it,
right?
Because that's the best way that it has the most response,
but I'm trying to tell jokes.
When you hear a person give a speech and they have that weird sorta artificial
quality to the way they're talking,
we should reject that.
Yes.
I completely agree.
We shouldn't let them do that.
Yeah.
We should be like,
just talk.
Talk like a normal person.
Yeah.
What are you doing about the budget,
you know,
and have the budget yet an important priority of this administration.
It's something we think about every day.
Oh,
what the fuck are you?
What you guy was talking to you like that?
You'd be like,
stop,
asshole.
You know who else does that,
that exact speech.
Do that,
that type of language comes from corporate world.
If you were like,
if you talked to a guy and you're like,
I had a bad experience at your offices,
he'd be like,
you know,
every time a customer comes into one of our establishments,
they want that.
We want them to have opportunity.
We want them to have choices and what you'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That's corporate.
Like it's not how humans stop.
Exactly.
But you can hear the training video.
You get that sometimes when you go now when they go,
do you want to sign up for the um,
the special extra warranty?
You Go,
I don't know.
They go,
well,
you know,
when I had my computer a couple of years ago,
I knocked a bottle of coke over.
I love coke.
And it left the thing.
And because of the warranty,
they took care of it and you're like,
that's a training speech.
They tell you to make a personal story up and you're like,
I know you're saying that to me right now.
So know that feelings when someone's lying to you,
that when you're looking at them,
when they're just straight bullshitting you and they won't even look in the eye
looking down,
looking around and panicking as they bullshit you.
Sure.
There's the worst is if you know somebody that can do the.
When you know they're lying and they're not panicking,
you're like,
oh,
you're a crazy person.
You're a fucking sociopath.
And that's a weird moment when you're talking to a guy and you're like,
I'm not sure what you're playing this game and I'm not wearing a hat right now.
You know what I mean?
I'm not wearing a hat.
And you see it on your head.
I don't.
I'm not where I'm with it.
Especially if they get stuck in a bad situation.
Yeah.
They get stuck in some site where they did something Douchey,
[inaudible],
you know,
like wow.
Crazy.
People are so strange.
It's so weird to run into someone who just doesn't see things.
It is been like you.
You see the world and they see a gigantic galactic conspiracy to ever tell you
about this comedian who will remain nameless,
who came up to me and just start showing me pictures on his iphone.
He's was like,
look at this,
and I'm looking at it.
It's pictures of clouds,
right?
I'm like,
I'm thinking of the cat's beautiful clouds.
He goes,
look at that,
and we just keep doing this.
He shows me like 10 of these and I go,
he's an older guy,
so I'm trying to be considerate.
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
Pretty cool.
And he goes,
you know,
I've been seeing them for years.
I go,
well,
are they?
He goes,
they're alien craft that goes,
these are Ufos.
They are.
They've been coming in various forms.
I see them.
I've been taking pictures of them.
It's incredible that,
you know,
no one's paying attention to this [inaudible].
This is a very strange thing.
And I'm like,
am I in a sketch?
I'm like,
because he fucking with me because if he,
you know,
he's a kind of a silly guy and I'm like,
if he's fucking with me,
this will be kind of.
And then I realized,
Oh,
wait a minute,
I'm dealing with someone who's got a screw loose.
There's a screw.
It's not,
it's not worth supposed to be.
He's not 100 percent crazy.
Like he's very functional for the most part.
He's,
I enjoyed talking to him.
He's a nice guy,
but when it gets to,
he'll pull out his fucking iphone.
You gotta run,
you gotta get out of there because you're going to be looking at pictures of
clouds and he's gonna tell you about spacecrafts that have been contacting them.
Yeah.
And it's.
But other than that,
he's normal.
He goes,
do you like cheeseburgers on cheeseburgers?
Yeah.
Your fries.
Hey,
can you pass me the salt?
Please show.
So what's going on man?
How's that?
How's the road treat you like you have a conversation with her.
Then if you get into,
I know a guy like that and it's,
you think he's like a,
just being,
like,
I'm kind of a storyteller.
He starts telling us stories and you're like,
there's a lot of exaggerations in these stories and then you're like,
you know,
he kind of rambles on and on,
and then he switches topics like real fast to have like a whole new story.
But it's about something like,
he's like,
you know,
I got shot six times and you're like,
what?
He's like,
yeah.
So I was over,
I was in the,
um,
like the south in South Carolina.
I was going past Columbia and I got it.
And it's a new story that starts and you're like,
yeah.
And then this guy helped me and then we were up in the trees and then this guy
pulled out a nine millimeter and he has like everything and you're like,
wait,
I thought we were talking about,
we're talking about fishing or something.
And then he goes back to like,
um,
yeah,
you know,
when I went,
um,
I took a hot air balloon.
Oh,
I bought a hot air balloon company.
And number of years ago,
and I took this money that I got from this investment into in mines and I bought
this company that takes hot air balloons up in the air,
is it costs me a quarter million to get the startup.
And you're like,
what?
You don't,
you make $10 an hour,
what are you talking about?
Like it's just story after story.
Yeah.
And I'm like.
And then I start Kinda like I don't know what to believe.
And then part of it's fun to believe and I start to think for a second I'll stop
and be like,
are you an improvisational like genius or you like a,
like a brilliant Improv guy right now.
Is that what's going on?
Am I getting like played or something?
Pumped.
And then.
But then there's something you see in the eyes where you're like,
oh,
I don't,
I really think there's,
there's,
maybe I'm,
I'm talking to somebody who has a form of mental illness and I'm not,
it's not,
it's not the type.
What makes you go like,
um,
I dunno,
like maybe more scare or maybe like sillier.
Like it's not you.
He has all the intelligence and you can talk about like what should we eat now
and you have a normal conversation about that and then it goes off into like 10
different storylines.
It's almost like it's his fault.
Yeah,
it's not.
It's not at that point.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how your brain works,
man.
You know,
what don't I,
I'm guessing.
I always guess when people act like,
why the fuck did you do that?
Like I have to like stop myself sometimes and go,
I don't know how his brain works.
My brain would process the same scenario in a different way,
but maybe his brain would handle some shit.
You know,
that I can handle very well.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how you think,
but I know when I see someone who's just not,
we're not.
There's a missing connection there.
Like I feel like this guy's like,
he's missing a whole piece.
Like what's going on here?
Sometimes you can see it from the moment,
right?
Like there's some who.
Oh yeah.
At the moment you're like,
but it's scarier when you have long,
normal conversations before that.
Then you're like,
what?
Like has this been there the whole time?
Yeah.
I've,
I've talked to people and then like 20 minutes into the conversation you realize
that crazy [inaudible] yeah,
like some,
some people it takes a little while.
Some people it's like right away.
Does the dangerous,
crazy,
dangerous,
crazy have like sparks to them.
Like you'll just want to back away from dangerous,
crazy.
They give off an older kid.
You can't be dangerous.
Crazy.
Unless you have this like a certain amount of danger to your odor.
You just feel weird.
It feel weird to be around.
Every dangerous dude I've ever known has a slight intangible odor about them.
You know?
You're just like,
okay,
get the fuck Outta here.
You know?
There's those dudes.
Smells like the current farm.
Yeah.
It doesn't need more.
Yeah,
but not even.
That's dangerous.
Those are just silly people for the most part.
It's just fucked up.
I feel like that with almost with a super negative people,
the people that it's not good for you to be around.
You pick up on additional vibes from,
you know,
like just being around them.
Yeah.
You don't know what it is,
right?
It's the smell.
It's not like they give off heat,
but if they leave,
like if you're just meeting them and they leave the room and like,
let's say you just brought somebody in right when they leave,
you're like,
feel bums off with.
Yeah.
And you go,
something's off with that guy.
Absolutely.
She said their eyes for me because I always look in the eyes for a second.
You can see like the worriness or that friendliness sometimes.
Yeah.
Or sometimes they just smell crazy.
I remember Brian Cowen had this chick wants and he brought her over and I mean,
and I'm not bullshitting within three seconds of meeting her,
I knew she was nuts.
Really?
Yeah.
Like he,
he brought her over and uh,
they introduced,
you know,
hey,
this is Joe Joe,
this is whatever her name was.
And I go,
oh,
hi.
I go,
Nice to meet Ya.
She was high and I go,
come here for a second.
I go fucking crazy.
I go,
what are you doing?
He goes,
what are you talking about?
I go,
dude,
that girl is fucking crazy.
I go,
trust me,
you gotta,
get the fuck out fast.
You knew fast.
I locked eyes with her and it wasn't a nervousness.
People get nervous if they see people that have been on television sometimes.
Yeah,
but that goes away pretty quick.
Once you start talking,
usually they're weirded out,
but you can see what the weirded out was.
This was like black.
This was a like,
like a crazy person just like.
I was like,
what are you doing?
Callen?
Like she wasn't bad looking.
She's very attractive young lady,
but unfortunately there was something wrong with her mind and years later Brian
was going into a bar and he ran into her and she was a streetwalker wow.
Couple of years later,
yeah,
it turned out she was cranked out on math and while he was,
you know,
mildly sweater,
she's doing meth and it them awhile to figure it out,
like exactly what the fuck was wrong with her.
And he tried to fix her.
Oh really?
He was doing that and then he gave up on that.
And then he runs into her and he's going to a bar and she's a streetwalker move.
He probably cut out the part where he slept with her again.
This one
he did one last time recently.
These scabs.
When's your last checkup?
I don't want to use a condom or not you.
You're special to me.
You always use condoms?
Don't know.
A lot of me.
Yeah,
she's a hooker but she always use condoms.
Don't worry about.
It's good girl,
man.
Yeah.
He said it was really super depressing,
but it was.
I smelled her.
I don't know what to describe it.
I mean it would suck if I was wrong.
She was like the nicest person ever.
But I wasn't wrong.
James.
Exactly what it was.
Warning him about.
Ranger has a smell.
You're dangerous.
It's assumption.
Don't know what
the fuck.
Cock sucker.
Bert Kreischer and Joey Diaz,
lazy gentleman.
They are actually doing it.
Podcast,
a live podcast which is the perfect spot for it.
Right next door at the ice house.
And they're doing that at a 8:30.
And is that going to be on Ustream or anything like that?
Or just on itunes?
Just on itunes.
Spiritually.
You smell that.
You don't have to see it smells crazy.
Bird bird that you uh,
what's it?
Victoria's secret's perfume that all the strippers were.
That's what I think.
Crazy.
Happy.
Yeah.
Doesn't wear Kimonos.
What you trying to sign?
I saw a friend of mine's tweet the other day like,
oh,
I gotta go shopping for Cologne.
Look.
And I'm like,
oh no,
you don't.
You don't ever watch out for puppies on the floor.
Powerful.
Those porn stars.
She just bind about their dogs
or
powerful Joe George Saint Pierre podcast was fucking awesome.
Yeah,
it was cool.
I wish he could have stayed longer than an hour.
That's a long time for most people.
But he was super cool to talk to him.
Did he?
So what's the wrap?
Does he,
does he really think he got abducted by aliens?
He really thinks he got a Dr Balian series.
He,
um,
he thinks that it's possible that ever since he was a little boy,
like he's been missing time.
He misses time sometimes.
Can he thinks it's possible if they take him and he didn't want to let talk
about
fucking Nick Diaz and to get ahold of that.
Well,
you know,
one man,
he fights like a fucking alien.
Joe.
Did you read what it could be like there's somebody on your message board put
like,
Oh,
wikipedia page where it said it could be like five or six different things and
you know,
one thing and there's actually,
when we were talking about driving on the highway,
that's actually a condition like highway hypnotism where you just get hypnotized
by the highway.
But like the constant,
like a motion that's.
And then it also
said that,
you know,
some people say it's aliens,
but I think you should just do the gopro thing.
Yeah,
just record yourself.
I tell you what I saw in my boss was not what was under this Gopro.
Tell you I saw a Ufo man.
I'm not fucking lying.
Ufo.
Calm down man.
And take me to another planet fucking lying to you.
That's my best.
George St Pierre was pretty good at first when he says,
are you like,
that's cool man.
I don't know what the fuck's going on with him.
Yeah,
that might be true.
Imagine if it was true when I was.
You got to deal with him and the aliens.
Good point,
man,
and at some point I've heard before,
but it's still a really good point.
He's like,
imagine if you were a fish and you are in the ocean.
That was great.
You are living your life and all of a sudden a man come in with a hook and pull
you out of the water and you come back to tell your friend like,
look,
I saw you
Scott.
If you'd like to get the fuck out of here,
you're crazy.
That was a really good point.
I was on the plane laughing hysterically.
Yeah.
It's a very good point.
Yeah,
it is because look,
we.
The fact that we exist at all is insane.
People with cell phones driving around in their cars talking to another dude.
I do that on all the time in my car.
I was talking to my friend Tommy.
He lives in Connecticut.
We're talking while I'm driving around and in real time and just just taking it
for granted.
It's just completely taken it for granted.
We're crazy amazing.
Pulling fish out of the ocean with giant nets and shit just and throwing all
this shit water in their kit.
Daddy here.
Just dumping all our pollutants.
We don't give a fuck.
We're gangster with.
There's water near us.
It's no good water in New York.
There's no good water.
You can't drink any of that.
You can't grow fish in any of that.
All that water's polluted with like,
yeah,
you know it's the Hudson
the way it is.
Just the way it is.
Yeah.
Fucking animals.
Just throwing glass and shit and Piss and tampons and rubbers
and bodies.
Bodies like fuck.
Fucking dead.
God.
People from New York come up with a Jersey cylon Sundays.
It's like a big day for them.
Like we'll going into Jersey on fucking Sunday and they go over and they fished
and they catch eel.
No grill up.
What the fuck?
It's just an email that got me on.
It.
Just made on the yield from the fucking Hudson.
That's why I ain't scared of not cancer.
They can suck my dick.
The yield from the
I'm in.
We were in Jersey one time and me and joe on a bus headed to a UFC event and I
showed him this pond and I said,
look at cancer.
It was late cancer.
It was cancer.
Like this pond had a move that no movement.
It had like a layer of this green algae,
which really wasn't green.
That's just cancer bro.
They,
you know,
New Jersey.
They've been dumping shit since the seventies,
since the sixties,
Bro.
But that's never going to be.
That's what's what's.
What's that word?
Record low record.
Mobile,
reconcilable.
Know the other word when you can't reverse directly,
you can never reverse that soil and
that soil in New Jersey,
when they built the metal lands,
I remember how many animals all of a sudden I had in my living room because they
tore all that down that wildlife and next year and I was seeing.
I remember one night seen a possum the size of a small people
treat fucking tree.
You saw me
walk like a fucking ate those things.
When you,
when you call the police in Jersey,
I've got a possum here.
They shoot the fucking thing.
You don't shoot snakes or the naughty.
They shoot the fucking possible because they play dead and then when the cops
leave they fucking get up and they brushed me.
You can run over a fucking car with bicycles and throw names out of brush
themselves off this
behavioral trait.
They play Dave fucking planes that were playing possum.
Oh,
I seen a fucking possum that looked at me one night at like four in the morning.
I looked at him.
I was like,
what the fuck?
And he jumped on a treatment it like he held onto the tree
and I was like,
this is fucking mind boggling.
I saw skunks that look like fucking like monsters.
You know that.
What do you think those didn't they just.
We had this discussion on your show a year and a half ago,
but in the bronx they found a rat that was just amazing.
Like it broke all records.
The length of it is a type,
I think it's called the Zambian.
Are you being something wrapped?
So I'm from America.
It's a pet.
Oh,
how about.
And they've let so many people have let these things go.
And like how Florida has the python problem,
they have this rat problem.
It's an invasive species.
We let go of one of those.
Pythons in college were part of that.
Laura,
you went to school in Florida.
Scariest fucking day of my life were moving out of that apartment and I'm,
am I,
you know,
how you move out and you've got clothes everywhere and I'm just digging my hands
into my buddy comes in the room.
He was,
oh,
keep a lookout for my python and know what we lost it at the middle of the year.
Like,
and it's just in our house and as well.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait,
but wait,
what do you mean we lost it?
We.
Okay.
We got broken into by,
uh,
by these dudes and we had dogs.
Me and my buddy hardly had dogs.
Body cheese had a python.
He put both his dog.
She's got,
she's to fucking torture this dude.
Fucking green stuff is bay breaks and went mountain biking one time.
Holy fucking.
But we forgot about it.
We briefed his brakes on but he didn't go and then two weeks later we go and we
forgot.
We increased them.
He just like,
what the fuck?
So yeah,
these guys broke into her house and our dogs in our rooms and then they broke in
the house and they let the fucking snake out fucking broke into the house.
Stole all her shit.
Let her show you.
Not totally responsible for it.
Somebody else let the snake out.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Did you ever Diaz as.
Did you ever see a banana?
Right?
How do you know?
They didn't just steal a snake.
A [inaudible] [inaudible].
She was like,
I don't know if it's been in there or not.
The fucking lid was open.
They looked for it.
That I don't know.
It probably in the last assholes are allowed to buy snakes.
Any asshole like this anywhere.
Responsible Savannah monitors.
I was into reptiles.
Big Ticket.
You got a pit bull and I think that they should give you by a pit bull.
You need to take a ged.
That's a particular shift with they when they should definitely,
definitely make you answer questions and they're dangerous animals.
I'll go a step further and saddle think single women in their 30,
she'd be allowed to adopt dogs.
Why do you say that?
Because they have fucked up their life now.
Let's stop it there.
Let's cut it off there and not let them to.
Have you ever seen up.
Look,
this is.
I'm taking a stretch and I know what I'm saying.
So I'm seeing a woman in the thirties,
mid thirties,
like 35 when the.
When they go,
that's it.
I'm comfortable with being single.
Now I'm going to get a rescue dog and then you go hiking and that dog goes after
your kids because they don't.
Are you sure that they're really comfortable with being single and it's probably
hard to find a good dude man.
Yeah,
but you never had those women that get the big dogs and they're like,
it's a rescue dog.
This is my new project.
They want some love.
Yeah.
And exactly.
And then they don't fucking discipline it and they just let it go from fucking
bananas,
psycho fucking dog.
The
dogs get really protective of their owners and if they sense that their owner
might not be like,
you know,
very dominant.
Yeah.
If it's maybe it doesn't have deep voice,
something like that.
The dog might be extra protective.
Was your pit bull dangerous?
Yeah.
I had a pit bull encounters or one dog killed one of my other dogs.
Why?
I came home in the middle of my living room,
one of my females that killed my other female.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You can have two female dogs together.
Female dogs apparently will always fight over dominance.
Whereas a male and a female,
they accept like who's who's the boss?
Usually the male just lets the female,
like fap,
she's leave me alone.
Like female staffers,
jaws in the mail like sort of gives up.
But the females never give up.
They never give up the position.
They'll fight to the death.
They fight and then they give up and they figure out like who wins and who
loses.
But then the challenge,
the one who lost,
wants to go back out again and they did it a couple of times and I thought I'd
gotten them over it.
I separated,
um,
and I did all sorts of different things and then I started letting them be
together again because I thought they would had gotten over it because I felt
like maybe it was just some like animosity,
like it was too fresh on each other's mind.
They had gotten into a fight,
but it's so normal for that breed to get into fights,
you know,
they're beautiful dogs with humans.
They're beautiful dogs with humans.
But with people with rather,
they have just this incredible killed drive.
It's like nothing I've ever seen.
My dog killed two cats.
Um,
he killed squirrels.
He killed anything dumb enough to get in his yard and he would kill lizards all
day.
Like we had these lizards that would run around and he,
that was his video game.
He would just run around with his paws on the wall,
trying to get these lizards just running around the perimeter of my house trying
to get lizards.
In hindsight,
I look back and I'm like,
what a crazy animal to have.
You've got a monster.
You got to monster.
It loves to attack things.
He,
but he was a very particular type of dog.
He was,
um,
a hog dog.
The origin from the Argentinian?
No,
no.
He was a pit bull.
Well,
he was from Hawaii.
It was from Hawaii and they're there.
They breed them to be super animal aggressive because they're breeding them for
hog hunting and so they all,
they have longer ears and the ears pick up more of a scent and they're larger
dogs.
He was crazy.
He was beautiful dog though.
It was awesome with people with people who the greatest thing ever.
He was awesome.
He was just amazing buddy.
He was like super smart.
He always wanted to hang with you.
You always be down to wrestle.
Like I never felt in danger to do Jujitsu with him.
I take us back,
you know,
I'd go tell him to put the choker and they'd be like,
he lady who to kiss me a buddha.
Have you do like,
I would be like choking him and he would kiss me.
He was a sweet,
sweet,
sweet dog with people,
but with animals to another who's not to be trusted,
who was not to be trusted.
It was the craziest thing.
It didn't.
I didn't have anything to do with socializing.
I socialize them with other dogs like right away he started fighting with other
dogs.
What time?
He was a baby.
They got,
they.
People yelled at me at a dog park when he was a baby.
It was like four months old.
He was trying to bite other dogs.
He was just gangster like from the womb and I was a fool to try to control this
animal is in pet,
you know,
like my dog now.
The big one,
Johnny.
He's the sweetest dog ever.
He's a sweetie.
Like my other dog.
That's a much smaller dog that she believed.
New bulldog mix.
That dog tells him what's up.
And Johnny goes,
all right,
all right.
He's just like relaxed.
We lag.
Just lets it all go by.
You know.
So you think it's it?
They're born with it though,
is just like people how their bread is buttered.
Bread.
Yeah.
They encourage a certain type of animal aggression,
aggression towards animals.
They encourage it.
They encouraged fighting and it's been that way for thousands of years and it's
the cruel aspect of the dog fighting though is what makes amazing dogs because
the ones that survived through that horrible ordeal,
that genetics that were passed on because the dog that quit and the dogs that
are cowed and backed away from a fight were killed.
They were all killed.
That sounds horrible to us because we love our dogs.
Sure.
But they weren't looking at dogs like that.
They were looking at dogs as a way to make money and the way to make money.
I mean,
you're talking about like this probably went on from maybe the turn of the
century on.
I mean it's probably something that's been going on even before that.
If you could really get into the history of it,
but they.
They bred dogs specifically for fighting.
They bred them specifically for that.
Had them on chains.
They would put them.
There's a dude that I know that was a famous pool player used to keep 35 pit
bulls.
It was this pro pool player,
35 pit bulls at his house.
They weren't as pets.
They were fighting dogs.
Crazy man.
There's.
Yeah,
craziness,
man.
I think big boi from outkast used to do that too.
Well,
that's a big part of the culture.
He bred those dogs and he read the,
the,
the bully ones that are stocky.
He,
he never went to his website and looked at him.
They're expensive.
You know,
big boys website.
Well,
yeah.
Well it's purple ribbon in the,
in the world of fighting dogs.
This is where it gets really squirrely because it's not like I'm trying to
glorify this world,
um,
and get,
give it morals or anything like that.
But the reality is in the fighting dog world,
you're not supposed to sell the puppies.
They're called puppy peddlers and they're looked down upon.
You're only supposed to let your dog breed with,
with really respectable breed.
So you're going to make some crazy killer dog and men will loan out their dog
and like you see like the lineage written down like you know,
rough riders,
Bronco and subtle stables,
Sheila e dot,
you know,
and that's the dog's precedent.
And they all know the championship bloodlines.
That's totally illegal to have dog fighting.
But the shit has been documented.
It's like very thoroughly.
It's the same thing with chicken fighting.
Like they have champion chickens.
Like I know a dude who raises chickens and he fights them,
you know,
there's this old Mexican dude,
he's cool as fuck,
you know,
and,
but that's his culture man.
He grew up fighting chickens and this guy knows like championship bloodlines and
they breed the right chickens with the right hands.
Like it's been a part of human history forever,
but it's,
it's like in the shadows and the darkness of our,
of our world.
And we don't want to admit that in 2000,
whatever it was,
nine or whenever,
when,
when he got busted me.
What,
when,
what year was that?
Two thousand nine.
Maybe eight or nine.
Maybe.
It was some time in jail.
Yeah.
We never want to think that a guy who's capable of such great heights is being
like this massively successful football player could also be capable of such an
insane crew.
So insane.
I got to tell you,
I love dogs.
Like,
I mean,
you know,
you guys all did me a huge salad doing the fundraiser for the dog last week and
I love dogs,
but I still,
I also have a problem with people who don't let somebody like him.
I'm like,
serve his time and then get another shot at like earning a living again because
a lot of people were suit,
like rightfully recruited critical of what he did.
Right.
But you know,
he lost his name.
He lost hundreds of millions of dollars probably.
Right?
Absolutely.
His contract was like about the biggest at the time he had crazy endorsements.
He went to prison,
which is what the punishment was.
He did it.
He went to prison and he did his time and then a lot of people were really upset
that he even has a chance to make a living.
Right.
But it's like he,
we,
he,
he paid the price,
right?
One denial is his fucking talent.
The NFL is like,
you know what,
come on back.
Come on back.
You know why?
Because if they don't do it,
someone else going to do it.
Yeah.
Some,
some.
Someone's going to grab that guy.
No,
it really wouldn't be any other way to play football.
I mean that's kind of A.
I mean there's the nfl and there's basically.
That's it.
That's the,
there's the,
the b league is not really a League for football.
The idea that
Rina.
Yeah.
I played that for for a day.
I
don't know if they drug test.
It's just fucking brutal.
It's brutal.
It's like being in the yard.
Canadian football has some good.
Had some good athletes for sure.
Good players,
but NFL is definitely the top of mine and he was a bad motherfucker.
Doug flutie Canada
first and play up there for awhile before he came down to America.
He was the hero when I was in highschool.
Doug flutie was like,
I think I was in high school and he was in college.
It was the hero.
It's right.
And then there was the USFL was very famous in Boston.
He was right.
Yeah.
He was super famous.
Have you seen the 30 for 30?
Who Killed The USFL?
Yes.
Fucking great.
Donald trump ruined that Shaylee.
Yeah,
he just ruined it.
He did it.
That's all.
Those are amazing.
That's the best programming.
ESPN or basically any 30 for 30 documentary.
What are the stories that will fucking kill you?
They.
It started.
The concept came up last year was the 30th anniversary.
Billy Corbin did the first one.
That was about the.
You had a podcast.
That's up.
Billy Corbin is the guy who did cocaine.
Cowboys broke,
broke,
fucking broke,
which is amazing.
Cool.
Fucking guy.
The Fort Lauderdale Improv and hung out.
Yeah,
cooking.
You fucking.
You have them on the EU when he shows all the fucking Michael Irvin,
those guys in front of clubs and he goes to Miami.
Dolphins use to ask the college guys to get them into the club.
You watched the trailer for the you of you.
Why'd you go like thing was Florida state.
We hated them and I fucking saw it.
It was like it was a bunch of black gangsters with a white coats that go out and
be black gangsters.
Motherfucker,
slow
white guy.
Go the black of the better.
I want you to bring it back.
I want high fives.
I want fucking chains.
I want everything.
I want you to not celebrate.
I want you to fucking humiliate these motherfuckers.
And then the guy from two live crew came out with his own.
He had a fucking VIP and they will come out to hit my dick.
I'm on.
And those bitches knew what time it was and that's all.
Listen,
there's two things that drive black people to different levels.
That's when they hear two live crew.
When they go to red lobster,
black people lose their minds at red lobster.
Fuck Popeye's.
On Tuesday you take,
you go to Sacramento,
red lobster on Friday at about 4:30,
when they blow the whistle,
blow the whistle.
That assistance they weighed 300 with the hills.
What are you showing over there?
That's the trailer for what?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's that documentary is that.
I don't know if that's all over the u.
He did Bertha conquer with me.
Well,
I got to remember this.
Write this down.
Yeah.
That motherfucker was given out blood test.
He was coming up positive and giving somebody else.
This guy that was smoking dope all the way.
The NFL warrants.
Interesting that when you have like football players and basketball players,
they make rules on like how they're allowed to celebrate.
Yeah.
Especially like the football thing that's like you're not allowed to dance.
Hundred percent score a touchdown 100 percent because of black.
Yeah.
And they're like,
dude,
if you blacked it up plenty.
So let's dial it.
It really is.
This is a white man.
Probably didn't enjoy probably quite old with a cigar with a white suit.
Yeah.
It's not a coincidence.
I love when people in the US to go,
well,
the greenish clockish child sudden listen,
listen,
stupid.
There was a guy named dexter the MOLESTA
defensive back,
the defensive back that used to fucking group Krazy glue all over.
So.
Oh the
other guy,
he didn't stutter.
People brought up with balls on his shoulder because he was afraid of getting
your ass dog be upon you.
What your mother.
Hey Shit.
There's a rule I got to touch.
You're five feet from the line of scrimmage.
He was banging it right from the line.
He come up on your spirit.
What?
What,
what?
What?
What was his name to Lester Hayes?
Defensive Bachelors and Ronnie Lott Total.
Joe Rogan about Ronnie Lott.
They told him he couldn't play in the game phase.
They cut his finger off during the game.
They were like,
who the fuck gets his finger cut off during the game?
He had,
he had caught his finger on a helmet.
He was like a cannon ball.
Cannon Ball and just like total disregard for body and like and like this is
before good.
Hellman's and like he would just annihilate people.
He was the assassin and he got his helmet caught in finger,
his finger caught in a helmet,
pinky and they went to the locker room and they're like,
all right,
well you know,
we're gonna need these.
You're gonna have to put like five stitches or whatever.
Twenty stitches in your finger.
He was like,
Nah,
I want to go back out there.
And they were like,
well you'll,
we'd have to cut off your finger if you to go back out there.
He was like,
do it,
do it.
They'll just fucking cut.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
They could've fixed it.
They could have fixed it,
but you wouldn't be playing that day.
So he said cut the playoffs and shit.
How much of the finger?
The just like.
So there's no,
you don't see the nail.
Like maybe that was an annoying part of his whole masturbation
ritual.
It was secretly hoping to chew it away.
Anyway.
Powerful job.
So right next door.
Um,
you'll be able to get that on the church and what's happening now,
right joey on itunes.
There'll be able to get yours with burt church.
What's happening now?
Yeah,
it's on itunes.
I was drunk.
I,
one of the greatest storytellers in the world has ever known what he called me
when I was in New York and I was drunk.
I don't know what we're doing.
I don't know if you're doing a standup show or a podcast or you're doing a live
podcast,
then you're going to do our standup show.
Yeah,
yeah.
Then I'm doing that.
Yeah,
but why you by just saying,
Oh fuck,
I don't like that podcasts.
Well,
it's an interesting one because it's a small room.
It's only like 50 people.
I'm just going to sit there and giggle my fucking ass off.
You know,
today we're driving in the car and he goes and we're talking about health.
And he goes,
AH,
dog.
I went to the doctor today.
I dropped my pants and the doctor looked up at him.
He goes,
hey,
you know you got toilet paper on
pass through it.
He goes,
I want to wipe the helmet before I went in there.
The helmet,
I did notice a little piece of toilet paper hanging off the end of the day.
Hey,
Dick sneezed a little.
You know the answer as Joey.
Hey Joey.
What's,
uh,
what's your first p of the day?
Smell like listerine and gunpowder got shot out of an alien.
Sasol.
It looks like
Piss looks when you take too many vitamins on an answer that Oh my God,
he um,
was it on your podcast that was on that?
He said,
you know,
black people eat to talk
bikeable sleep to eat,
to talk
to the
rest of the talk.
Yeah.
Dad,
why did you let him do that?
you were there.
It wasn't.
Oh my God.
It just happened so quickly.
And your dad asked for them?
No,
you joyce grown ass,
man.
If he wanted one,
you crack them open and he goes,
here you go,
Mr k.
and just dumped somebody like that.
What is it?
And he goes,
candy,
popcorn,
you like it?
My sit down,
sit down and go,
dad,
there's marijuana in there.
And he goes,
no buddy,
it's good.
And I go,
I go dad.
And then Joey's laughing hysterically.
I'm like,
what are we going to do about this?
My sister has lost her fucking mind.
Everyone's like,
oh my God.
And so yeah,
but,
but he was,
my dad was fine.
You can't do that.
The photos are photos that
I don't agree with doing that at all.
I did it with my own dad.
Remembers.
Yeah.
But that's his dad.
That's your thing.
It might now.
My Dad would never say that he took it knowingly,
but um,
I am way in my head.
I'm like,
there's no way joey slipped it to him.
He must've said something.
Maybe he just your dad,
your
dad didn't know what the Fuck Joey said.
And he's like,
yeah,
sure,
sure.
But he probably has brain blacked out.
You want to get high with me and Mr Kay,
Mr Kay and my back.
Dad,
just such a question.
Come on Cock sucker.
What do we gain games are we go deep,
deep,
deep in me?
Yeah,
that's exactly what happened.
Is full of cookies.
Is wolfing down hurt to have one cookie and our cookie
times when someone's talking to you or you're not even paying attention because
you're thinking about something else and you're like giving them like a small
percentage and you're trying to figure something out you.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What are like taxi drivers?
You know,
you just hear the main words money many times.
My Dad has dragged
king of that and I know,
I know when he's playing chess it's like,
I'll be like,
what's up man?
He's like,
I was uh,
doing shows.
Yeah,
man.
He's like,
he's in front of the computer and I can tell he's like,
hold on a sec,
hold on a second.
I'm like,
alright.
He's like,
so what's going on?
I can be like a robbed a bank today.
He was like,
wow,
that's neat buddy.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I'm saying right now,
and I go,
what is it fucking rook tonight?
Something?
And he's like,
yeah,
I play chess man.
Just tell me on the phone,
on the phone,
you call me back
fucking whack.
We should do dad,
you know,
travel channel Green.
They said they would pay for us if we want to do an adventure because if they
can hear it,
they're like,
well,
if you guys want to do anything,
we'll fucking,
we'll pay for it.
What do you mean?
I was sitting there,
we were talking,
we just hadn't had a dinner and there were um,
they asking questions or just kind of getting hip to the podcast scene and they
were asking questions about that,
like,
what is death squad?
And I was Kinda just don't tell them
particular to try to explain,
you got to go.
I was like,
if you don't,
no,
you don't know,
you don't know.
And then they were like doing like,
so these are all your buddies.
And they're like,
yeah.
I was like,
do you ever want to do anything with them?
Like,
and I jokingly said,
I said,
yeah,
we kind of just said this because Duncan said at one time ago we kind of want to
take dugout canoes into the rain forest and see if we can find Iowasca with our
dads.
No,
just us,
just us.
And so then.
So we were talking about dad.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I don't know why.
You know what,
how'd you get there?
I have no fucking idea how my brain it.
You know what I was thinking unrelated journey.
I was thinking,
I was thinking we should do a show where we all take our dads and go do shit.
In my head I was like,
oh,
I have a better idea.
You know what's fucked up?
He was actually talking about people that do that very thing earlier on the
podcast.
Very negative,
very,
very negative way.
It was about liars.
Oh,
it was not that at all was his.
But he was talking about was about how,
you know,
how some guys will go out.
So what do you guys want to go see?
The movies wouldn't believe this man,
but I'm about to start a billion dollar a year business kind of crazy.
But uh,
we're taking this from the ground floor and Tommy was like,
you make $10 an hour.
What the fuck you talking about man?
Well,
you know,
once,
once we get the startup money,
which is basically guaranteed.
Yeah.
I got a couple of investors that got it.
I got to,
I got an Italian,
I,
one in Czech Republic and we were talking about what movie to go see.
Well,
how the fuck did we get here?
Yeah,
that's where you kind of did.
I just did,
did that
almost exactly like that.
I was trying to.
I was like,
my dad doesn't want to be on TV.
I don't know where he's going with this,
but it's exactly.
It's funny on TV at all.
My Dad will be on TV.
You're saying that your dad would enjoy it as a fascinating guy.
I mean,
my dad's a very nice guy.
He's,
you know,
he would be very polite and friendly with everybody,
but my dad,
I don't think.
Let's do it.
Dad Show what?
Pick it back up my nose.
There's no way he would never do it.
No.
It's zero desire to be famous and we cast it out for you.
Give me like a black guy,
black guy.
Black Guy was only a couple of years older than me.
Four years old.
Like Bernard Hopkins plays my dad and no one even mentioned it the whole time
though.
And Bernard Hopkins refuses to admit it's him playing it on the show.
Sure.
And afterwards,
in every interview is,
I don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
That's not me,
but it is him.
Take Bernard Hopkins will go fishing with him.
I can't have to listen to it.
You have good stories.
Listen and tells me,
you know,
I'm listening to this.
My Dad has to bring back childhood memories,
but like it's like when joe was a kid and he first learned how to ride a bike
like Joe.
You remember when I took Joe to the holiday and you remember that Joe and making
some motherfuckers lying in his bed playing with chimpanzee doll.
Bernard Hopkins owns the right to the,
to the title.
I am the machine.
How do I know that's a.
maybe that might be an API,
right?
Get outta here.
You tarnish your reputation and doubly later brother,
we'll see in a bit.
Bert Kreischer will be joining us tonight.
These sold out ice house,
kind of a club show along with his man that I'm talking to right now,
Tom Segura.
So exactly what.
And I wasn't thinking of him at all,
but it was perfect.
It was perfect.
You sort of,
you know,
but it wasn't.
No,
he wasn't.
He's not a crazy person,
but does,
he?
Does make me think what we were talking about,
which is like a lot of times I go.
How does fucking Birch brainwork yeah,
I think that all the time.
Yeah.
How did,
how did he get there?
You know which being you do when you're sitting around?
He's not even high though.
He didn't even get high.
No.
So he's got no God damn excuse you just showed up and I just didn't know where
it was going with the dad thing.
I was like dance on vacation,
adventure.
But somehow those things do connect in his brain.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we go.
I don't think so.
I'm just waiting for an opportunity to talk about doing something together.
Yeah.
I think it was more that I do want to go chameleon like fucking really bad.
Do you guys ever used to go?
Meanwhile,
middle of the night fucking forest is on fire because Brian left behind when it
lit cigarette to I don't want to go canoeing with Ui up there in a river.
Wait,
what happened?
You,
you like spiked your dad?
Like you didn't finish that or when did you do that?
To your dad when you told them you were doing it though,
right?
Whoops.
Hey listen.
I mean sure you did.
Well,
you brought it up.
Remembered on me.
Joe Joe gave me this big bottle of pop soda,
you know,
that was made out of marijuana and uh,
I had it in my fridge for awhile and then me and my fiance at the time,
we're all recording ourselves like a,
cause my dad was in town for the night and I think I put the camera down and
then he is like,
oh,
I'm going to have some of this wine or champagne or whatever.
And I'm like,
that's not champagne.
That's okay.
Yeah,
you can drink that.
And then I just like let him drink it.
And then like in like within like half hour or so he just became so giggly and
just laughing and it was really actually one of the coolest things ever because
like,
did he freak out at all?
No,
not at all.
He was just like,
almost like a happy drunk,
but where he was just kind of giggling and laughing.
Did you ever tell him what happened?
No.
Never be probably,
no,
but you should tell him because he would enjoy it.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean maybe it'd be one of those things that he discovered late in life,
like wow,
their slates makes life so much more enjoyable,
but you'd have to get it to them in that form though.
Right.
That's the coolest forums that the edible forms the best form.
I think
I like it the most.
Oh Shit.
Sorry.
As long as it's mild,
as long as it's not like super strong,
the effects are like really pleasant.
Superstrong can bring strong is not good.
That's a terrible feeling of.
I'm just trying to relax and get through this day.
I don't need to be contemplating the fate of the fucking galaxy youth.
Do you like in a super strong to psychedelic?
Is that what happens?
It is very much so.
In fact,
in a lot of the ancient Hindu writings,
a lot of what they talked about,
really extreme psychedelic experiences that they,
uh,
they talked about it.
We're all from eating hash.
Really?
Yeah.
Eating cannabis can,
if you eat enough of it,
you can have an experience that is every bit as strong as mushrooms.
Really?
Yeah.
You just have to eat.
A lot of it.
I've had.
I've been moved to tears a few times.
I've had experiences in the tank.
Eating,
eating pot are like a fucking,
like a ride to the movie,
like experience that you wouldn't believe if if you.
If you didn't see it with your own synapses,
if you weren't going through it,
it seems impossible.
It's all just eating pot,
eating pot and getting into a tank.
The tank filled with water and the show,
but you have to eat that.
You got to get to that critical level where you feel like you eat too much.
That's where you gotta get you gotTa.
Get to that feeling where you're like,
oh,
I fucked up.
I fucked up,
and that's when
you can close your eyes and see nobody.
Shit.
Like how much are you talking about?
Well,
you see it in the dark.
See,
that's when you see it,
like you don't see it.
If you open your eyes,
if you open your eyes,
you're not going to hallucinate.
It's not like it's going to misinterpret visual cues and real information,
but what it will do is supercharge your imagination to the point where it can't
deal with a blank slate.
So when you,
when you eat the pot,
you close,
you either close your eyes like I've had this habit on planes before where I ate
a cookie before I got to the airport,
and then while I'm on the plane,
you're tripping your balls off.
When you close your eyes and the darkness of your closed eyes,
that's when your imagination starts firing.
When you start seeing wild,
crazy neon colors like fucking,
you know,
like you,
you start seeing like,
like computer cartoon,
fractal shows.
It becomes very,
very bizarre and that's just closing your eyes on a plane inside the tank.
It can really like.
It almost like opens up another realm of experience.
Kids.
Very strange because in the absence of light,
this,
all this stuff flying through your brain sort of manifests itself as visual
information.
You don't just get the feeling like life's slipping away.
You get,
you get that feeling when your eyes are open,
but everything looks normal.
You know,
everything looks a little faker and everything looks kind of two dimensional,
a little closer that it should be,
but it still looks normal,
but when you close your eyes,
then you get the fucking color show.
Just madness and craziness in front of you.
Yeah.
I've had an absolute freak out.
Oh my God.
Blowing my mind experiences eating it.
Yeah.
You just have to eat it.
How much do you have?
What's the most you've consumed like?
Well,
there's always going to say.
There was a friend who made pills.
He made a thc pills and I forget how he did it.
I forget what his process was of extracting the thc and putting it into pill
form,
but he told us very specifically,
only take one.
He said,
do not take more than one.
I only took one.
I listened to any bravo took to eddie.
Bravo was one of those silly bitches,
like I can't even get to high.
It's impossible to high.
You could and it was unbelievably strong.
Just one.
I was like,
where is this?
Do travel in everyday this do it is going to cover raising town every day and
that's something that a lot of people are overlooking about this whole medical
marijuana movement.
Everyone's focusing on smoking pot.
We don't want people smoking pot.
Well,
the eating pot is five times stronger,
five times more psychoactive when you eat it and you're getting guys just
loading up these cookies,
loading up these candies,
and you can eat three or four of them before you even know what the fuck's going
on and then an hour and 20 minutes later you're on your deathbed.
You're freaking fuck out.
Like
Yoshi,
like banana bread.
Joey ideas actually had a funny story from a long time ago when listerine strips
first came out for that pot,
listerine strips and they used to have like the little containers just like I'm
in it and he had a whole one in and his friends,
I can,
I have one.
And he takes it out and they had all melted together and there were like nine
strips melted together and is it says like,
oh,
I guess that's it.
You know?
And then I gave it to,
I guess the guy called the ambulance like 10 times the amount of those strong,
super strong to take one half of those breast trips.
It's really hard to find them now.
They don't have them anymore,
but I used to take one half of one and that's all.
It took.
One half of one you gave me that one time.
Jesus Christ.
That was when we were headed to the east coast.
We were on a red eye and I remember,
uh,
we,
we both landed and you were like,
that is the highest I've ever been in my lab.
I go right there on that plane.
And you go right there on the plane?
Yeah,
I go.
What was that like?
Was that with.
That wasn't an adventure.
Yeah,
it was.
And I also remember that I buzzed by no means not high anymore.
When I said that and I felt like leg 11 hours later,
I was like still kind of feeling it right?
Like yeah dude,
that shit kicked my ass.
It was unbelievable.
That was only a half.
I can't imagine taking more than that.
I actually started after that I realized that I'm like,
for me to not have that feeling a quarter of a strip was,
was better.
You know what I mean?
Like I could function on a quarter.
Yeah,
not on the half men.
I don't like eating anywhere.
I had one the other day and I didn't think I felt it the whole night.
Like I took around 8:00,
around 11 or 12.
I was like,
all right,
I guess so that was just a shitty edible.
Then I couldn't go to bed and it started like my heart started going crazy.
I was like,
all right.
Now starting right now it's like one in the morning and how long did it take to
kick in?
Four or five hours on a blockage somewhere,
son.
That doesn't even make sense.
That doesn't make sense.
You just defied logic.
You defied science.
You broke medicine,
but I couldn't go to sleep though for like hours.
Wow.
Maybe just took you a while to realize you were high or were you like caffeine,
dap and maybe it was having a hard time getting in there?
Yeah,
I think I must have had too much other food in my stomach.
Maybe it just took a while to digest it or that's another possibility if you ate
something heavy,
right.
If that's behind it.
Is that happened?
Is it working with that?
I think so.
Totally right.
Yeah.
It was like busy.
Is your body has to do is break it down and just get to it,
which totally unscientific when it comes to understanding of the digestive
system.
You know what I'm saying?
The juices.
Break it down the brain juice.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think we were right about that,
but yeah,
the uh,
I think if anybody should be concerned about experiences,
it's the eating it because I don't want anybody to have bad trips,
man.
Yeah,
it's bad trips.
Steer people away from weed and you don't get anything
out of those bad edible trips either because they usually come when you don't
expect them.
Like they come when you're trying to go to a movie,
have a plot cookie with your friends,
go to a movie and Giggle and the POC cook who fucking.
Everybody just wants to go home,
you just got to get out of there.
Everybody wants to leave.
Panic is never a good time and that's what it is.
You are in like you have super anxiety.
Go.
At least I do.
And that's not like,
that's not fun man.
You don't go.
That was really cool to add panicked for my life for a few hours,
you know,
just from sitting there when I was in full panic mode.
Okay.
From taking this one one a pill when Eddie Bravo had taken to.
I was in full panic mode and I was talking to this dude and the dude I was
talking to was say a very high level Jujitsu guy who also apparently was a
rapist and a while I was talking to him so high.
I mean I'm just so hard,
really shouldn't be talking to anybody,
but why I'm talking to this guy.
I'm like,
man,
this guy is a fucking killer.
Like he's got this.
Just feel about them.
Like he feels super dangerous,
you know?
He's a like a really high level Jujitsu guy,
but he also feels like,
wow,
like if you were alone in the woods with this guy,
you know,
and you'd gone for a few days without food,
he might fucking eat you.
And then later after that had happened,
he turned out that he was a rapist.
He got arrested,
but he didn't.
He didn't get arrested by the way he fleet.
And the way they caught him was he started doing Jujitsu again.
He couldn't stop doing Jujitsu and they started doing Jujitsu at a new gym and
he didn't realize how obvious it is that he's like a super high level guy.
It's not that many high level guys know when you get.
I mean there are quite a few,
but I mean it,
you know,
maybe maybe there's hundreds,
but the people in the Jujitsu world are pretty much aware of a guy that's that
high level and this guy was just tapping everybody,
including their best black belts.
And everybody's like,
okay,
what is this?
Who is this dude?
And he says,
he's from Brazil,
and so someone's got a picture of him or something.
And they went,
oh my God,
that's that guy.
And he's wanted for rape.
He couldn't.
He couldn't go on the Lam and not do Jujitsu.
That's incredible.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
I mean maybe they would've gotten them anyway.
I don't know.
Two things.
I got to have his Jujitsu and raping people.
Grape juice.
I got to be able to do both of those things to be a happy guy.
Yeah.
He gave off this weird dangerous energy,
you know,
especially when you're that cranked out on the wrong side of the pot.
Rainbow,
you know,
it was just.
I was in the never world I was in the world of fairies and elves and dwarves and
monsters and dragons in the night.
Well that's the things.
If you're having that,
that type of a experience,
that trip,
you've eaten too much and you happened to be in a not cool environment,
like if you're in an already dangerous situation.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Somebody get us home,
please.
God get us home right now and get us out of here.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's bad spots in the world.
Imagine eating a cookie and go to Karachi in the middle of Pakistan watching
people pull up with mopeds and gun people down.
You see that on vice.
The dangerous border went.
Oh,
fantastic.
Amazing.
What an amazing,
amazing access.
We had shane it in here.
He was telling us about Karachi and how insane it is.
That looks insane.
Like millions of people on this one.
Giant city,
I think it's $20,
million.
Something crazy.
A lot of people and crimes.
Just running a muck.
Who says they hate their neighbors so much and they are hated so much too.
So crazy.
He.
The way he described it to me,
he was like,
it literally is like the scariest place on earth.
Like you can't believe it exists.
It's like the apocalypse in a city and it's there right now and nobody's talking
about it.
Nobody.
Nobody even thinks about it.
When you talk about dangerous places,
people talk about like Detroit.
Detroit is not nearly as dangerous as karate.
Have you had Malan?
Have you ever had him on the show because mailed on Johnny?
No.
Who's that?
He's a comic from Pakistan.
From from Karachi.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Whoa.
He's really good comic.
Like where's he from?
Like this in America.
Does he live in la?
He lives in La.
He came over when he was 19.
How do you say his name again?
Kumail.
Nanjiani.
Yeah.
He's a really,
really good comic,
like really good moms casts a long time ago,
long time ago.
I mean he's very successful,
like he does very well.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean he just did an hour special.
He's a,
he's acting in like all kinds of like he's,
he does really well and he's like,
he's a super really,
like the thing that I was obsessed with when I had him on was that he didn't
like,
he grew up there and he didn't,
uh,
he didn't like watch standup growing up and he came into college at 19 and he's
so good at it that I'm like,
yeah,
but I just don't understand how you're good at it because like how is your sense
of humor developed?
You started at like basically 19,
like being exposed to this at all and he's like exceptionally good at it.
So you,
you see like he just has such a command of doing standup,
like everything,
like really insightful,
smart,
really,
really good writer performer.
It's so funny and I just fascinated at his whole background,
his whole story.
Yeah.
That is interesting because there are cultures that do not have standup comedy,
right?
I mean yeah,
he definitely didn't have it.
They all have some sort of public gathering before someone gets to talk.
But for entertainment,
I mean how many places have it
just breaking out in some parts of the world now?
Like I know in a lot of Spanish speaking countries,
you know there are clubs now and you know,
a stand up show,
a unit for television,
but it's not,
they don't have the like basically 8,000 year history of that we have,
are they coming from the catskills and it being like a thing that has different
genres.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it's newer in boys invented here.
It's totally ultimately invented here.
But there's a lot of confusion or a lot of questionings as far as who invented
it.
I mean,
who the fuck invented it?
Is there anyone who is known as the godfather of stand up?
That's a good,
that's a good question because stand up sort of became standup with lenny bruce
just before that.
It was like a lot of guys that would share jokes and they would,
uh,
they would do the same sketch for 20 years and you know,
they,
they would go perform in the cat skills and they would all steal each other's
material and shit.
They were like,
people in show business almost like you would think of a contract studio person
from like the 19 forties and fifties,
you know,
you think of those people that have contracts with the studio and did all those
studio movies.
Well,
these guys kind of were,
that,
there were like,
it was a different kind of comedy.
And then Lenny Bruce came along and all of a sudden he starts talking about real
shit.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden you start,
it's like,
you know,
like breaking down our use of language and why do we have to say this?
And who's talking about real scenarios in the home and,
and like,
Whoa,
like that was,
you know,
like if you go over my house,
there's all these lenny bruce posters everywhere and it's not like I listened to
Lenny Bruce a lot.
I mean I've certainly have.
It's not like it even holds up to this day because it really doesn't.
It's really hard to laugh at Lenny Bruce's stuff.
It's hard to put yourself into that mindset of the people that lived during the
19 fifties in the 19 sixties.
But if you could,
if you could go back in time and you would be below in a way,
I'm sure of it.
I'm sure his point of view was probably so incredibly unique at the time and his
insight,
you know,
his jokes,
some of his jokes today are great jokes.
He had this joke about homosexuality being illegal.
So what they do is they arrest you and they put you in jail with a bunch of men
who want to have sex with you.
Yeah.
You know,
it was,
it's a good job.
I mean,
it's,
it's funny in 2013 and he probably told that in the fifties it's crazy,
but people were like,
what?
I'd never heard anything like,
did he just say,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
Lenny Bruce went to jail for it.
He went to jail for using bad words.
Like,
people don't understand that.
That is in this past century.
People have been locked into cages for saying naughty words,
not even threatening.
Not like saying I'm going to blow up this plane and not,
not,
you know,
words like that,
but a word like fuck or shit or tickets or something like that document.
You're going to jail now.
They drained his money,
ruined his career.
Jesus.
Yeah.
That in the smack.
That was the other thing we need to learn from guys like lenny,
don't stay aware from my friend.
It seems like nobody gets through this Mac.
Okay.
Nobody does.
There's no recovery from that.
I had a buddy who had a hard time kicking it.
He,
um,
uh,
in a pill form.
He hurt his back and uh,
the doctors immediately,
of course gave them heroin or Oxycontin says oxycontin.
And he was like,
dude,
he goes,
it was,
it was magical.
He goes,
a cured,
cured all the pain.
He goes,
uh,
I didn't.
It wasn't even that fucked up when he was on it.
He was,
he goes,
I was just a.
He goes,
it just stopped the pain,
you know.
But then coming off of it,
he had to take some other drug.
It's my friend Tommy Jr,
if he's listening right now,
profit Tommy Junior.
Uh,
and they just give them to you man,
when you get hurt.
Like I know guys who were junkies and went to the doctor and you know,
they give them pain medication and you know,
that's dangerous trip.
Like you're getting high,
like mark,
mark it down because here it comes,
you know?
Do you like being sober?
You like keeping your shit together?
Don't take that.
That's no Bueno.
Know.
And you take that pill to the painkillers with a beer.
Yeah.
Ooh,
it's,
Oh my God.
Other ballgame.
Most people do.
Yeah,
like super common of course,
but not supposed to.
Right,
right.
Really?
Isn't Xanax a really bad one to take with alcohol?
Yeah.
I saw a lady do it on a plane and she was laughing about it.
She's like,
you didn't know
just a glass of my want glass of wine and my Xanax and I'm good to go.
And she was like laughing.
She puts her fucking goggles on.
Sorry.
Later.
Rule it on the chair.
She.
Yeah,
she was letting everybody know she was abusing drugs.
Yeah.
But if I let them know,
if I said,
listen,
I took a pot cookie an hour before this flight.
I'm out of my fucking head.
Right back the gate guys.
Yeah.
We're going to turn this thing around and landed in the desert.
This a fucking criminal monster off of our to us whole.
What were you thinking about?
Just thinking about finger girls in high school,
what was that all about?
Just having a flashback to the excitement.
The first time we touched a moist vagina,
like holy Shit.
I mean girls that would grab your Dick and some girls.
Wouldn't you have those girls that like everyone would pass around?
Like during movies,
like when you had the projectors out and they like,
oh we got to some girls.
Yeah.
There was some girls that would just let it do its finger on.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
You need your posting things balanced.
This
universe,
you know,
and it's not necessarily a good thing that those girls are so needy that they're
doing that.
But there's a cause and effect and it's not her fault.
You know,
that's what people have to realize whenever girls do like really overreaching
things to get attention,
it's because they didn't get enough attention.
You know,
it's really that simple.
Or they have the wrong kind of attention there.
They got fucked up and it's not their fault man.
You know?
And that's,
that's something that takes a long time to figure it out.
You don't realize that from what I mean,
people just sort of judge people by what they see.
And that's one of the more interesting things about having children as you start
judging people by how they became that thing.
How did you get to be this,
this angry,
like really deceptive,
you know,
shitty,
selfish person who's ruining lives and stealing from people and how does the
person get to be a murderer?
Has a person get to be a robber,
breaks into people's houses when you know they're not going to be around.
And how do you get to be that person?
Well,
some a bunch of shit asked to go wrong.
You know there's a bunch of people have to fail you,
you know,
you,
you started off nothing but potential.
That's what a person is.
Nothing but potential and that is the number one thing that we don't pay
attention to and it's the number one thing that's fucking up this world is that
people are raised by people that don't have any idea how to raise the most
complex thing ever.
A developing human being.
It's the most complex thing we know of.
It's a thing that literally can create an atomic bomb that can blow up the
fucking world.
That's how.
That's how powerful the human mind is and you're leaving it to assholes.
You're leaving it to a bunch of people that have no idea how to raise a person
correctly and weren't raised correctly themselves,
so I have all sorts of baggage that they're carrying into this,
this relationship between mother and daughter and father and son and the,
you know,
most people have no idea how the fuck they got into the place that we're at
right now.
They live their life on momentum.
You know,
and raising a human when you're stuck and momentum and screaming at people at
traffic and calling your wife a current and kicking your dog and now you've got
a baby.
You okay,
this guy has a baby.
All right,
now what happens now this baby's fucked and he's being raised by a shithead and
that's most of what's going on in the world.
Most of the problems is a lack of compassion and a lack of compassion from birth
to adulthood and it's so common and it's not being addressed.
Nobody talks about it.
Everybody wants to talk about oil.
Everybody wants to auto.
What do we do when we run out of oil?
What will we do when peak oil becomes a problem in this country when we step up
and learn,
but nobody looks at the number one commodity that humans have to offer.
That's humans are best commodity as humans and the more potential that you can
have in that commodity,
the more the better the world would be for everybody.
But the problem is that the people that have billions of dollars are a bunch of
cons and they want to hold onto that money with their greasy old moisturizing
cream fucking leather hands because they've had it their whole life and they've
been in this position of privilege and they understand what it takes to make
$16,000,000,000.
You know,
when people.
I had a payoff,
you know,
I'm a lobbyist.
I had a bride,
him just fucking boat,
you know,
but that's the,
the,
the extreme form of,
uh,
you know,
the,
the wrong parts of the competitive aspects of capitalism.
Do you see Uc Riverside?
No.
What is that?
Oh my God,
what is it?
It's a documentary.
It's so fucking.
You're not the first person to say,
what is it about?
It's about the guy who,
um,
he started.
It's the world's biggest time shareholder company.
Westgate,
I think it's called,
or it was called,
something like that I think is westgate.
Anyways,
a few years ago he went about building the home in the United States.
Oh God.
It was 90,000 square feet I think.
Okay.
Ninety thousand square feet and it was modeled after Versailles,
the palace and France.
And he just so happened to be doing this and a documentary crew was filming him,
you know,
for this purpose.
And it happened in [inaudible] eight when the market crashed,
they had a lion.
This is phenomenal.
Forty three year old mother of 8:00.
Choose most beautiful girl in the world.
It took me a while to fall in love with him.
We have a great relationship.
There's 30 years between us,
but he doesn't need at least there is that option.
If he does,
I don't know if 10 years from now
we never sought out to build the biggest house in America.
It just kinda happened.
It's bigger than the White House.
Two tennis courts,
full size baseball field,
kitchen,
antique furniture,
thousand square feet.
I'm like,
God,
no.
This is my room.
That's my closet.
Nothing's really normal about this life
in line to do a billion dollars in sales for the year.
We're on top of the world
and it came to a screeching halt.
The market fell over 700 points.
I would say it's touch and go right now we don't talk about
financial problems.
I guess I'll have to watch the movie to find out what's going on in my life.
Everything changes.
This is almost like a riches to rags story.
She knows we need to cut back,
but she's still compulsive.
All they could afford a watch.
I would tell you
our problem is vegas.
Our lenders are made it very clear that you will have more money than he knows
what to do with human.
Go back to building this house.
If the turns over this building over my dead body,
you can buy the palace that timeshare mogul David Siegel already wants to sell.
Just think of the brace side.
You may not have.
The
American dream is raising way up above what you started with and that is what
she has done when you're down is when you found out who your true friends are.
You get strength from your marriage.
No,
I'm in this fantasy world,
you know,
she is completely oblivious to how she should come.
Comes
off.
Well,
when they start having to make cutbacks,
yeah,
there are cut backs or things like we're not flying private or flying commercial
and like she picks up like one of her kids they land and that she picks up her
kid at the airport and she's like,
what's that?
What do you think of flying commercial?
Was that crazy?
And the kids like,
I don't even know you're talking about like you're just planes,
right?
She's like,
yeah,
commercial.
They go to rent a car to visit her friend at the airport and they're like,
it hurts.
And then she's like,
so will the driver like meet me out front or how does this work?
And he's like,
this is hertz rent a car.
She's like,
what is that?
Like there's no driver.
And he's like,
no,
you're the driver.
You're renting a car right now.
She's like,
okay.
I just,
I don't know.
All right.
Flow like that.
That's pretty removed from society where she's,
she's living in such a fantasy world.
How much money to homeboy lose?
I mean nine figures for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
But he's been a $100,000,000,
so over 100 million for sure.
Of,
of personal lap.
And think about that nine figure.
Yeah.
He lost a substantial amount of money.
Oh my God.
And then you know,
because of properties basically.
Basically what happened was his business is a luxury business but it's a luxury
for the middle class.
So timeshares or something where it's like if you have a good job,
like you know you can more than pay your bills.
You can afford to do something.
Like let's go to Disney world this year,
let's go to Vegas.
But they sell you on whether you can afford to do this and it's people who have
that,
you know,
extra money,
some disposable income but not like.
So what does it mean?
What does it mean when you have a timeshare?
Was I mean like you have this month and I have that money.
It's exactly like that.
It's like you get to come to this awesome timeshare,
whichever way you like Vegas,
you have the timeshare in Vegas and two weeks out of every year maybe you get to
pick your month if you pay more or sometime during the year,
less savory July.
You get your vegas place,
it's yours and it's fully furnished and it's awesome.
But other people have the keys to it.
Yes.
So it's not.
Who are the other people though?
People who like you signed up for the service.
Yeah,
like your friends know.
No,
it's total strangers.
See?
Yeah,
but there is a property.
There's a property manager that's on site for you and then you have to go
through him that you're basically tell them if you're paying to go back to the
same place,
then ambulance,
this is my shit,
but you know it's not,
but it's not really.
You don't keep a TV there and you don't keep stereotype.
I mean,
it's probably,
I'm sure furnished with all that stuff,
but what happened was probably for a lot of people more comfortable than going
on a hotel definitely.
And probably better.
Like if you can eat my felonies,
do it all.
That's the thing is that go to a supermarket and shop like you're at home and
you can get a,
a way higher end place than you would if you were renting the equivalent at a
hotel.
You're not going to get like a three bedroom suite,
like you're going to get at your timeshare.
But how much do you have to pay here?
I don't know.
There's not that much.
Uh,
it's probably,
it's like the one I went to a,
I actually got suckered into doing one of those timeshare when I was 18.
My stupid roommate,
he was like,
Hey,
I want a vacation.
And I'm like,
oh Brian.
And then we went
to Florida.
He's like,
well we have to do is find a way to Florida.
And then we have five days in the Bahamas.
And I'm like,
fuck.
Yeah.
So we get there and we had to like fly and spend her own money to fly to Florida
or we could have drove there and then we get there.
And then like the first day we checked in to this hotel,
it was all paid for.
I was like,
this is sweet.
Uh,
he was like,
all right,
well we got to go to this condo thing.
We have to just do this little thing for a couple of parameters seminar.
And he didn't tell him.
He totally did not tell him that we had to do this every day.
Like for two hours a day,
except for like the last two days.
How many days were you there for?
I think five days.
And so every day they just went to a new level of trying to.
And everyday I would say the same thing.
I'm like,
I'm 18.
I was like,
do you really think I can do this?
I Howard,
how'd you even give me here everyday?
What were they saying to you?
They would show us the condos,
which they were all amazing,
but they would walk us around and then like the next day would go to a different
part of,
at the time it was Florida,
like this is what happened.
It's like last two days was in Bahamas.
He didn't tell me that either.
He's just like five days in Bahamas.
But what was,
it was in Pompano,
Florida the whole time.
So he just went to all these different,
like,
whoa,
these condo places in Pompano.
And they were like,
this is this so-and-so place.
And I know that was in the Bahamas now,
not the first three days.
The last few days
they take a boat cruise thing over to the Bahamas.
Uh,
like three hours to Obama's on a boat in three hours.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
And so then,
but what sucked is like every day they tried to get you to sign this contract.
And it was like fucking,
like hardcore,
like they were like,
no,
you need to sit down here and talk to,
you know.
And I'm like,
look at those young guys who were the guys that,
you know,
these were older,
older guy,
you know,
what were they saying to you?
They were like,
do you understand you're at the perfect age.
I'm sure your credit,
you know,
this will be a good investment in your life because you can like,
rent this out,
sub rented out and you will always have this really cool place,
you know,
in the pompanos or whatever they're telling you that if you don't use it for the
weeks that you get it,
you can rent,
you can rent it out to other people and making profit from it so easily it's
going to cost you this,
but you could rent it.
Right?
Exactly.
And I wanted to,
I want to say it was probably something like he paid once,
like a huge chunk of money.
Like I want to say it was like something ridiculous,
like $10,000 and then every year you pay like a maintenance fee or something
like that.
That's like $200,
I want to say it's something like that.
So it's a top heavy sort of thing.
Yeah,
definitely top heavy.
And they were like,
they were saying like,
look,
we have the best financial solutions we have.
These are we,
we are friends with the people at the bank.
We will get you the best rate that we can get you for 20 years,
you know,
to,
to divide that 10,000 out to probably $30,000 after finance charges.
You know,
it's a scam.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's kind of a bit of A.
I mean it's,
it's one of those scams.
It's been around for a long time though.
The high pressure marketing scam,
you know,
it's like a legit scam.
Like you're allowed to
do that.
You're allowed to do that.
That kind of like high pressure shit if you're like socially awkward or weird,
you could really crack people with that.
You know,
I was just getting really pissed.
And the other thing you had to pay for all the tax of all the hotels that we
stayed at.
So at the end they were like,
all right,
you owe $800 in taxes.
So I ended up having to pay like back then like Ohio days,
$800.
We both had to pay $400 or something like that shit load of money that drained
my bank account and then like I only had $300 so my room,
my roommate gave me the extra hundred and then I never paid him back because I
was like,
look dude,
that was bullshit.
I'm sorry that you did not tell me any of this.
You said we had a free vacation.
I'm sorry,
but I didn't eat.
Made me spend an extra,
you know,
Blah Blah amount of money.
And so we stopped talking ever since then.
And then we became enemies for a long time.
And then just because over $100.
Isn't it funny how something like that wrong,
you could just decide that that person's enemy,
right?
Well it was just locked me out of 100 bucks.
Bullshit man.
It was like,
it's definitely not a vacation.
Well,
you know,
it's also,
it would,
they would probably have to pay you a lot of money to make you sit there and
listen to those people.
And in the end,
what you did spend,
you probably could have done almost the same thing with your 400 bucks or you
know,
or whatever the hell it would have cost me.
How much can you go to like on the cheap to the Bahamas for and stay in the
cheapest place possible.
I bet you we ended up spending more money between the two of you both got a two
bedroom.
The hotels were just like,
that was one thing I said like it's three and a half or above a hotel.
It was like very borderline.
It was like courtyard at the Marriott,
you know what I mean?
Do.
That's one thing about like uh,
I think has happened to the older you get to is like I will not compromise on
certain shit.
Like certain paper.
Well,
like just certain like,
like,
hey man,
do you want to go see this shit?
And backpack with like eight people that will see some Austin.
Like,
no man,
I don't want to do that.
Like if I,
I'm not saying I have to have four seasons and like I can't,
you know,
afford to do that.
And I'm not,
I'm like,
I'm basically not going to take a trip if I can't do it,
at least at a level that I'm comfortable with,
you know,
I agree with you most of most of the time.
But uh,
I,
you know,
I went on that show mediator and we've been camping for five nights in the
Missouri breaks.
But that's a trip.
Usury River brain want to do that,
that you want that experience.
I'm saying I'm not saying like if that experience were presented to me,
I would consider that for what it is.
But I'm not like I met a dude who was like,
you haven't been to the Bahamas.
I went on a mail boat,
like bringing mail over and like slept with like basically the mail carrier and
like the end the letters.
And I was like,
Nah,
you know what the product is that.
Yeah.
The problem with that is though I am the same way,
but I'm kind of grumpy.
I'm getting old.
I'm the older,
I get it.
But,
you know,
I went on this trip to Joshua tree where we stayed in this like little rv and I
was so against,
I'm like,
look,
you know,
I want to go Joshua tree,
but I don't want to stay in some shitty rv in the middle of some campground.
Like what can we just stay somewhere nice?
And I was being a bitch about the whole thing until we got there and it ended up
being the coolest adventure ever.
Like I would never have done it,
you know,
like,
or like I get like this girl I know wants me to go camping with her and uh,
I'm like doing the same thing where I know if I go I might have a great fucking
time.
I've just been grumpy.
But that's again,
like a specific instance
variance I think though too,
you know what I mean?
Like it's like it has the group called the group experience in mind going into
it is going something like that.
If you go,
if somebody goes,
hey man,
do you want to go to Paris right now?
And you're like,
okay.
And they're like,
now we're going to stay at this place.
Will you,
will have your own room or bathroom.
But if you get the key from the front desk,
I'd be like,
you know,
I'll wait on Paris for a little while so that I can,
stay in my own room or something.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I'm not,
I don't want to exactly
the lack of sleep.
You're going to get sleep on the dude because you know he's snoring and you
know,
you're snoring is going to wake you up.
It's going to be a goddamn disaster.
Last time I slept with a dude,
it's my friend Gary.
It was a coming to a ringtone.
Last time I slept with a dude or Dudette last time I slept with dude.
Um,
he uh,
he came to stay with me and he,
uh,
he didn't have enough money for a hotel.
He was out here doing like some shit from New York.
He's a comic as well,
you know,
Gary Valentine,
Valentine Kevin's brother.
And this mother fucker.
I never heard anybody snore like this before.
It's crazy,
right?
It was crazy.
In the middle of that,
I had a gap and go,
are you fucking kidding me?
But this was when we were kids.
We were both like in our early twenties,
just like in the early nineties.
Couple of years ago I stayed at the West Palm Beach head is a condo and I was
down there and my buddy chuck came to town,
Chuck's 65 to 90 big,
big dude.
And he was like,
Yo,
I'm like,
can I crash the condo is a,
has like a,
you know,
whatever,
a bedroom and living room.
I was like,
yeah,
he goes,
lays in the bed and like,
before I even can sit down I hear him,
uh,
like not just snoring but he also grinds his teeth.
Oh my God.
And it sounded like a monster was doing it because he's such an enormous person.
I laid on the couch
in that condo with my noise canceling headphones,
a sun,
like a shirt over my eyes so that like block it out and a mouth guard in my
mouth.
And he came out and he was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Like what?
I'm like,
if you,
man,
you came to visit and now you've ruined my night.
That's what happened.
That snoring is grown.
Like a grinding things to worse.
That's just scary sounding.
Yeah.
It's like,
why do people do that?
They say it's or whatever.
No,
I'm a clincher.
Like the dentist said like,
no,
that's actually okay.
You clench and that's why you have really strong.
Many of my teeth are cracked from weightlifting.
What?
Yeah.
Really your teeth are cracked from Ms Dot some serious weight,
man.
I'm a very strong person.
Yeah,
my man.
But yeah,
he told me where a mouth guard when I lift weights.
No Shit.
Yeah,
it's probably.
We do like squats years hitting the bag as well.
I only hit the bag with the mouthpiece on.
When do you.
When you bite down,
you know when you're really digging into something,
you actually lose a lot of power if you don't bite down.
It's really strange.
I don't understand it.
I don't really want it.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem like you can hit his heart when your mouth is open.
It's like your whole body needs.
It needs to work together as you explode out on impact and when your mouth is
open a little.
I think there's a lack of,
uh,
of power to that.
It's kind of strange,
but it's very difficult to get full bounty of,
of,
of power and explosive energy when you have your mouth open.
They actually did like tests on it and I think it was the basis of one of those
mouth guards they had.
They had like this power guard where they proved that like if have a bit down on
it,
it actually increased the amount of weight you can lift.
Really?
Yeah.
Like they aligned your jaw in a certain way that increased the amount of power
that your,
your body hand.
I don't understand that.
I don't know why that would be the case button for some reason.
You can't hit his heart when your mouse open.
That's really interesting.
I know like you know,
breathing can affect like how you like,
yeah,
like holding your breath versus breathing related to a lot of physical things
makes a huge difference.
Huge difference.
And being able to sustain like a an in and out breath versus like holding your
breath is one of the biggest issues in Jujitsu is breathing
me how to breathe.
Right.
And that's why the really the best guys are all really into yoga and Pranayama
and learning breathing techniques and stuff like that.
Because if you can control your breath and your,
your,
your diaphragm is a muscle that you can control.
Much like you can control your arms,
your legs.
And there's certain guys like this dude,
Hixon Gracie is like the greatest Jujitsu guy ever.
He does all this crazy yoga shit with his stomach where a stomach in.
It's really freaky to watch man.
But the guy has absolute control of his breathing.
That's incredible.
And because of that,
I mean not just because of that,
because he's also incredibly talented.
Just has a wealth of knowledge of Jujitsu.
He just,
he's a master,
a true master.
And on top of that he's also a Yogi.
Yeah.
Not that breathing shit is like.
It's super important.
Coordinating your breath with striking as well,
not just with the Jujitsu.
When you kick the bag,
when you kick a person,
when you breathe out as you,
as you strike,
you know,
and that's why.
And a lot of like the karate and uh,
even um,
I'm in Moitai,
they,
they like it not like the same thing that Kia,
like they yell out when they,
uh,
when they hit things and tie guys do that a lot in training like here and like,
you know,
and like in when you go to Thai fights,
they yell out like the audience or the trainers yellow,
the yellow out,
you know.
And um,
it's like,
you know,
like you're tightening up as you're delivering the shot and also to protect you
a little bit if you get hit yourself.
I know a lot of the,
um,
like the heavy bench press guys with,
they're trying to wrap out on heavy weight.
It's always a one in one out.
Take one breath in and push it out with one breath.
And that's how they try to do like two,
25,
like 30 fucking times.
That shit is like,
all,
you know,
it's better than going.
You hold your breath and you're totally fucks up the rhythm of it.
You know what's crazy and to do what's really hard to do that I enjoy doing.
I enjoy it as an exercise is a minute in a minute out.
Really?
Yeah.
I take a one minute breath in,
a slow,
one minute breath in and then a slow one minute breath out and it's very hard to
not freak out and just talk in the middle of it.
It's very hard to.
I do like 30 seconds back there at a lot.
I do it in the tank and that's how I start my tank sessions.
I start my tank sessions by completely controlling via always been alive,
breathing and.
No,
no.
I had a buildup to it.
Your Buddy,
uh,
was it that powerful denny?
Yeah.
Powerful.
Danny.
He,
um,
he said he does yoga like every morning.
Oh yeah.
Danny's a bad motherfucker.
World champion and he's been,
I've known Dennis since he was a young kid.
He's a great guy.
He's awesome.
Danny,
proper coast.
He's a,
he runs 10th planet Jiu Jitsu in San Francisco.
He's,
you know,
he's a young man,
but he's also a master race developing master,
you know,
as he's getting better.
But uh,
he's uh,
he's really into yoga right now,
Yoga and meditation and he had a few back issues and he actually gave me some
pointers and uh,
because uh,
you know,
I had some,
I had a bulging disc in my back that's actually been getting better,
but denny went through some back issues himself and he did like a very strict
regiment of yoga and um,
uh,
like,
like it was like a type of a tension.
It's like a spinal decompression where it's like literally like pulling your
neck while this cord.
And he did this,
like very disciplined over course of like five or six weeks or something like
that and fixed his issue.
Denny
has that quality too,
you know,
we were talking about how you can sense bad energy and less dangerous.
Denny to me has,
um,
like just being around him a few moments.
You sense like a type of balance?
I get the feeling from him that I do from a lot of people who are very
disciplined.
There's a certain intensity to them,
but there's also like a certain amount,
like you can feel like their control at work,
like there's such discipline characters a lot of times,
like really good athletes.
There's that like energy that they bring into a room,
you know,
like I know these,
like these guys that do like triathlons and stuff,
they have this,
it's like a quiet intensity to them.
Like you,
you meet them and you can feel their presence.
Their discipline comes through just in there
when they speak to you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Now the best time for people to be around the best type of people to be around
good influence.
Control apps.
Yeah.
Inspirational influence.
I agree.
And uh,
Denny Denny is definitely inspirational.
He's just,
I love them.
I love the fact that I've seen him as a young man.
So I met him when he was very young.
I think it was like 17 or 18 and he was always a cool kid.
I mean,
even back then it was great.
But to see him evolve and develop and become the man he is now,
I love seeing that.
Man,
I love seeing people progress and I love seeing people get it together,
you know,
like I was telling Tony Hinchcliffe the other day,
I had him on the podcast and I was like,
I love the fact that in the time I've known you,
you became a really good comedian.
Sure.
You know,
I love that.
I didn't know a guy.
He started out and then I meet him a couple of years later.
He's a great comedian.
Oh,
do this.
We got one right there.
That's pretty awesome.
It's fucking amazing.
He's great.
I love Tony.
Man.
That guy is so funny.
He's a total natural and like,
he,
uh,
the best comics are the ones that can't even help themselves.
Like if,
if a joke is in the room to be said,
he just jumped.
He dives on it like a fucking grenade.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I love that feeling with comics.
I love the um,
and I love seeing like I have so many friends who I started out with who I'm
proud of just watching them as my friends.
I brought a,
you met,
met full shown.
I brought it.
Oh,
I love that dude.
I mean,
he can't help himself either.
You're in the room.
Great personality.
That guy is the best fun and he's a.
When you're around,
I'm like,
he's all,
he's got a legit smile and then all the sudden you're smiling and everybody's,
he's a great guy.
There's certain guys like that,
like we only talked a little bit,
but I can tell right away.
He's awesome.
And um,
you know,
he had the week off and I asked him to come with,
to do the show that I'm saying Thursday,
Saturday and Sunday and he fucking like,
brought the house down every set it was honestly.
Yeah,
I would imagine he'd be really funny.
Yeah.
Anybody that came to the show,
it's Friday night and weekend.
Thank you very much.
You guys were awesome.
San Jose was the shit that was the shit.
Northern California might be the best place on earth.
It's awesome.
It really might be.
I mean,
the weather's not the best.
It's not the best,
but as far as like human beings as far as intelligence,
like vibing with human beings,
I think I vibed better with Northern California people than anybody on the
planet really.
I really do.
I have some friends that live up there and whenever I go to hang with them,
I always feel like,
God dammit,
why don't I live in northern California?
It's awesome.
It's better is it?
You know,
the weather sucks.
The Fat Dick Though,
unless you know that's only a negative if you don't enjoy sucking dicks.
Yeah,
but if you enjoy sucking fat decks,
I'm just talking from my own personal perspective and I'm not trying to be
sexist or homophobic.
Some of them are too big to really get in your mouth.
Right?
Especially if it's like a demon dick or a big giant word.
Harm the only ones a mouth.
Fuck you.
That's not beyond the realm of possibility.
I watched a chimp fuck a frog.
You know,
watching chimp fucking frogs face.
I'm.
No.
Has a video of it.
There's a video of it online and we've seen it.
Put CV.
Pull it up,
Jeremy.
I have seen a poor knows where I see the girl really struggled to get a guy's
soft dick into her mouth and I'm like,
that's a big Dick right there.
She's really struggling with his limp.
She like her mouth is all dry.
Wow.
That's really fucking stretching under all that.
Math is tough to generate saliva,
dry blow jobs that take too long.
Dry blow jobs take too long.
That's a
chimp rapes.
A frog maybe makes this frog suck him off.
So because we know this exists because we know that this chimp takes this frog
and picks it up and puts it on his little chimp cock and Fox it because we know
that exists.
I don't think it's that preposterous to propose that in an alternate world there
could be a giant boar that makes you suck.
His cock he wants to do is hold a personality flaw.
Rape in that mouth right now,
fucks it up night with them,
and by the way,
this is not the only time this has happened.
There's another video of a chimp fucking a frog.
Apparently when chimps get frogs,
they fuck them beat off using that fraud.
This,
this is some shit we never saw a mutual of Omaha's wild kingdom.
They would have edited this out.
We need the internet to give us this information.
Mutual of Omaha's wild kingdom would have you believe that chimps are cute
friends to be taken with on rides in semis on sitcoms.
This.
This is what they are.
Ship is busted.
I received this murderous frog rapers.
To be fair.
I bet it does feel pretty decent.
Probably feels good.
I feel better about your own impulsive,
like nature when you see that.
Yeah.
I would try snake that like,
like cut off the head and fuck the snake.
Not a bad idea,
but the whole you need a whole frogs have a nice big hole.
You know,
if you can keep them from clamping down on your cock and balls and I think that
maybe chimps probably have a much more leathery skin.
Then I think that was the whole idea in the beginning.
You know,
we had more leathery skin and then that's why the head retracted.
You have the sensitive tip and that's what makes you shoot,
but the average cock back in the day was probably a lot tougher than the Kochs
have today.
What is fucking dicks today?
They can't take branches.
Snap it into them are rubbing up against gravel where you fucking try to climb
up the rocks at the beach.
Now these cops are today or a week.
Yeah,
because you would,
you would funk,
you would fuck winches,
winches and you wouldn't wash it off.
You're just like,
you know that winches.
Is that what they used to become?
Winch a winch winches?
No.
Fuck a winch.
A winch is a thing you put on the back of a truck to pull a log out of a ditch
that's a winch,
a winch winches.
I think the look because I got in trouble for saying winches on fear factor was
you're like,
see,
I was just trying to motivate a girl.
And um,
she was on an all girls fear factor and um,
there was these other girls there were saying,
don't do it.
Don't do it though,
because she,
she was scared and so they were trying to make her more scared and I said,
hey,
I go,
listen,
listen to me.
Don't listen to those caddy winches.
Wow.
So what,
like what would a winch be today?
Like A.
Whoa,
yes.
The parent.
What they said what the why.
The reason why I got in is because apparently a wench is like a prostitute.
I mean,
we're talking medieval time folks.
Okay.
Is it really,
is that what it really means?
It doesn't mean what it means.
The cultural context and the cultural context.
Where I grew up in Boston,
a wench was a like,
ah,
fucking wench is like,
she was kind of a bitch.
She was like a little bitch.
I trust,
you know,
winches and,
and so a caddy winch would not be a prostitute.
It would be a chick that talks too fucking much and is trying to damage a young
ladies confidence in completing a challenge for $50,000.
Wench Patty wench.
But people get all upset they got or they got all upset and this was back in the
day and this is a fear factor,
like season two or something like that.
It's not like today.
If you said anything like that today,
you'd probably get arrested.
You know,
somebody tweeted like that rh sit on his recent podcast,
a punch drunk that he doesn't believe half the stories I say that story is
useful.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
what?
How?
Why would I wake make no?
How would I make that shit up that even me merely because you're a little
awkward,
right?
A little.
But yeah.
And you've been known to tell a story a bit on the exaggerating side
to make it more exciting.
Maybe.
Occasionally.
But that doesn't mean that you're not a liar.
I really think,
uh,
just need to follow me around to these massage parlors and stuff like that.
I don't believe me.
Yeah.
You also live an extraordinary life sexually that I'm sure he's not really able
to deal with that because he knew you back in the day when you were kind of a
zero and a.
I just hate that you were a hero.
I hate that shit.
I hate when you know.
It's stuff like that though.
Like I said,
hey,
if you really don't believe my stores,
why don't you ask now,
here's,
here's really what I think.
Why care?
Why was he,
why does he care?
Why do you,
you guys are friends.
What is that about?
You know,
it's about,
it's a distracting.
It's,
it's an energy distraction.
It's not something to focus on for him or for you.
He shouldn't have focused on it.
You shouldn't focus on it.
You know,
it's like in.
Sometimes you're on a podcast and you're ranting and he wants to keep it real
and that's really what he thinks.
You know?
There's that too,
but it's unnecessary.
It's,
it's when,
when you do that,
especially like with a friend you put out like a certain amount of energy,
you put out a certain thing,
you know,
you put it out there and then okay,
well then that has to be responded to it.
Like it's being responded to now and he probably didn't even think about that
when he did it,
but if he just said it or if he just thought it and then didn't say it,
it'd be way better off.
Or if he wanted to talk to you about it,
just say,
hey man,
I just want to tell you that sometimes you tell stories and I think they're
fucking.
I don't trust them.
Right.
Okay.
So.
And then I would say what stories are.
Yeah,
but you know,
you do tell a squirrely story on occasion.
I can't remember.
So I can have people that were involved in the story.
There are no,
no,
no.
Listen.
Okay,
well that's even more ridiculous because you're saying you've never exaggerated
or told the story a little
bit.
I would have to have an example.
You know,
I'm in high school,
never did it.
Like I'm saying,
like as an example,
I would probably be prone to saying something like,
uh,
yeah,
that girl was like fucking hot man.
She was like an La 10,
you know,
when maybe she was like seven or eight,
something like that.
Nothing like a slight exaggeration,
but I,
I
appreciate it when someone tells me the truth.
Like Ra would tell them the truth.
Go,
what did she look like?
You Go,
oh,
maybe,
right.
Maybe
he wouldn't say,
oh,
she was 10 greatest piece of ass ever.
You know,
everybody appreciates that more than they appreciate exaggeration,
exaggeration.
Although I enjoy it.
Like Joey Diaz style exaggeration is the greatest fucking thing on earth.
Absolutely.
I mean,
so in a way it's hypocritical so you don't enjoy exaggeration.
It's just saying you know,
enjoy that.
But you know,
Joey also tells them a very honest story as well with the crazy saturations
that,
you know,
or for comedic effect.
I mean,
it's like part of the fun of it all,
but that's also part of each of the,
these people's nature.
Like Ari is a guy who,
he's not like,
oh,
I'm going to add all this little spice to the story.
He doesn't like it when you do it either.
Right.
And he's a very specific.
Yeah,
he doesn't want you to bullshit him because he's not a bullshitter,
but that's his own trip to,
you know,
his own trip is that he's very like focused and ambitious now and he doesn't
want to hear any nonsense,
you know?
And,
and that's because he's on a great groove right now.
He doesn't want anything getting hijacked,
whether it's this time hijacked where the fake story or someone giving them a
fake impression of what happened.
Another guy who you've witnessed crazy leap.
Dude,
we were with Ari when he was first starting at the store.
I think when Ari came to the store.
I hate that.
I don't know this,
but I don't know if he's.
I think he started out his first sets in DC right now I think.
But then when he came over the DC Improv,
right?
Because I remember him having a hard time for them.
I'm taking him seriously.
You Say Baltimore?
I thought he was from Baltimore,
Maryland.
He's from it.
It's close enough close.
But he's not from Baltimore now he's from Washington DC.
But um,
he's from Maryland.
I mean DC and Maryland.
I mean they're like right next to each other.
Yeah.
In Virginia is right there too.
Anyway,
point being he came over here when he was fairly new to comedy,
you know,
but he was a really smart dude.
He was always a smart dude.
We became friends like immediately he was a young kid hanging out at the comedy
store and uh,
you know,
I remember at first he was like,
everybody's weird around people that are already like successful when you're an
amateur.
You're like,
you can't believe you're allowed to even talk to them.
Of course they get weird,
but then once you get past that weirdness,
he realized,
Oh,
you know,
that's just Tommy Lauren or Tommy Tommy Lawrence.
What's his name?
What's the fucking guys from in living color?
What the Hell's the Tommy Davidson?
Tommy Davidson.
A confusing with Joey Lawrence for some reason because the first time I saw Joey
Lawrence was one of the first celebrities oversaw.
Yeah.
And uh,
I was on the set of news radio and Joey Lawrence had his show right next to our
show is like a,
he had his Mercedes there and he was like,
he had his leg outside the car and he's like singing along to his own song.
And I was like,
and I showed up.
I was like,
it was kind of starstruck.
Holy Shit,
this Joey Lawrence.
Wow.
There's Joey Lawrence,
like singing his own his own shit.
Buy his own car.
So Tommy Davidson was another one.
I remember first talking to Tommy Davidson at the comedy store.
Tommy Davidson was like,
hey man,
what's going on man?
Like he didn't know who the fuck I was.
I was nobody when I first came to the store.
I mean I might've been a paid regular but I might not even been a paid regular
yet.
And then I realized,
Oh,
Tommy Davidson is just a comic,
you know,
like we're all just comics.
And then I always tried to be the same way with guys,
young guys,
young guys coming up.
I,
I always tried to make sure I let them all know we're all just the same fucking
thing,
just because that's Tim Allen,
just because you see George Carlin over there,
he's a comic there comics.
Everybody's cool here,
you know,
this is a cool environment.
And Ari was like,
one of the first guys that I saw go from being like,
you know,
like an open mic or to like a fucking legit headliner,
like a real headliner who comes up with an hours where the new shit every year.
It's pretty crazy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Who's great at your,
uh,
your,
your thing for your dog he was killing is both men and howling.
So important to have good comedy,
man.
Without good comedy I life would not be nearly as interesting.
Man.
Wouldn't be as interesting to,
to perform because you'd be looking around and all this other stuff and you
wouldn't be enjoying yourself.
You know?
It wouldn't be interesting.
It's interesting to watch.
Of course you're fucking clock is not right.
Brian.
I think me hours,
but it's an hour behind your thoughts on the while looking at your clock.
I'm like,
why do I have to pee so bad?
I haven't even been sitting here that long.
I'm going to take a piss and uh,
don't let him talk about anything too silly when I'm gone.
Hey,
no silliness.
A set time and we should talk about your podcast.
Uh,
you just,
uh,
just,
something really silly.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
oh my God,
I got it.
I got the silliest thing.
Poop.
I take a May 2nd.
I'm in Toronto and I'm doing this show at the underground comedy club.
And then May 17th,
I'm in Portland at the fun house lounge and we added a second show at 10:30.
How silly is that?
All right.
Hey,
I'm going to be May 3rd.
I'm going to be in Sacramento and it May 4th.
I'm going to be in Sacramento and May 5th or may be at Cobb's in San Francisco
and I'm bringing a Sam Tripoli and Tony Hinchcliffe.
Oh,
this is silly.
And you know what I was wondering,
because you've been doing some shows with your,
your,
uh,
your lovely wife,
Christina.
Has Jessica was Jessica and how did that go?
Do RDC a future of you guys doing on.
That's a lot.
That's what we're doing.
The 17th and 18th.
It has to be great.
We're doing Portland,
Seattle,
Ralph together.
Yeah,
man.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
dude,
it's going to be awesome.
See Ya.
This is silly conversation and your dog Theo,
is now better is coming with us and really bring.
Yes,
absolutely.
And um,
he is doing much better.
Thanks again for doing the show,
man.
That was awesome view.
Yeah,
that was really cool man.
Actually,
I met somebody from a bunch of people from cartoon network because of that.
And Really?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
They were at the show here at the show and they were like,
oh,
you were great.
And I'm ready.
Go checkout cartoon network studios pretty soon.
And maybe possibly pitch an idea to them.
That's a good idea,
buddy.
Me and joe ideas as cats maybe.
Oh,
I'm uh,
I got to talk to you about doing some shows that I think you would find fun.
Entertaining.
No,
dude,
I don't believe in rabbits that talk.
Dave rabbits talk had been featured in many cartoons.
It's the stupidest shit you believe docs,
but you don't believe rabbits.
No,
that's silly.
Rabbits.
Don't talk.
The carrots.
Actually,
I was really stoned and I was reading about who framed Roger Rabbit and how they
edited out all these,
like the artists,
like,
you know,
there's a scene where Jessica Rabbit pops out of the taxi and you could see her
vagina and there's a few other scenes where like a baby looks up address and
there's drool coming out of it.
The baby's mouth.
What's that guy's name?
Robert Fletcher.
No,
no,
no.
Oh No,
no,
no.
The opposite.
Jessica Rabbit I'm talking about.
Yeah.
The Guy Bob.
No haskins hoskins.
Bob Hoskins.
So then I found out that the only version that you can find that part in the
movie is on a laser dispersion.
There's only one version of that laser.
This ebay and bought it for $4.
Do you have a laser player?
I do in Ohio.
Do you have to go back to Ohio to get it?
Just so I can see her vagina.
Where do you.
How do you buy a laser player?
Because it's not like a turntables.
We still have turned to.
Right.
It's like literally the ones that are out there are the ones exist.
What's cool about the one I got is I got this really high tech,
like five disc change changer slash laser disc player and I was like,
this is like the best because it was on clearance for some reason and then like
two months later DVD came out.
I was like,
oh goodbye.
Isn't it kind of fucked up that the real sound people,
the sound freaks say that music played over a record sounds the best laser.
This is better than DVD,
but yet everyone went crazy on DVD a way better.
Is it better than blue ray though?
No,
it's not better in blue.
Right.
But
there's no argument that suck unless you have a laptop made by apple who can't
work out a deal with Sony.
I just feel so weak when I see a fucking Pcu or whip out his Bluetooth or Blu
Ray Bluetooth.
Look at the players are in the.
All the pc laptops,
a lot of pieces.
There's no laptop.
No.
None of the new apple fanboy saying none of the laptops today have DVD players
in this because that's blue rights.
The only ones that don't are apple ones.
Well they're actually taking them out of most laptops nowadays.
You take them out and wait,
why would you take him out?
Why would I take them out?
You take them out is you said no,
no,
no.
I didn't.
Laptops and laptops.
The laptops.
I'm not up on that,
but I did when I was at my friend and the Google friend's
house.
Um,
I did see the google laptop with the chrome operating system.
I got to play with that touchscreen.
Touchscreen laptop.
Yeah.
But it's all non local.
Everything is stored in the cloud.
Horrible idea.
That's what supposedly the next xbox is supposed to be where you don't buy
games.
All your games are on a cloud,
so you can only play if you have an Internet connection,
which drives me fucking crazy.
Can you imagine sitting there going,
I just wanna play video games.
There's a storm.
What the fuck?
That's ridiculous.
You should be able to
play if you're camping,
camping.
He set up a generator.
You shouldn't have to hook a fucking Internet connection to it through your cell
phone.
No
camping.
He can't get away from your xbox.
I'm such a second generation guy for that too.
Like I like people to buy that first one that needs all the work and then come
through in the second half of me,
my friend.
Yeah,
I know.
You got to get everything I can.
I love your dedication to seeing the Jessica rabbit snatch.
One of the,
um,
one of the episodes
as of this new show.
I'm doing Isabelle computer simulation theory and one of the things I'm doing is
I went down to a place that makes computer games.
Like they,
they,
they actually do like three d scanning and they scan my face and they're going
to put me in like this fake game with a creative.
Oh wow dude.
Way to use this show.
This show is,
I'm getting to do so much cool shit.
And most of it I can't talk about because I can't give away any secrets or
anything on any of the things that we found out.
But uh,
it's so much fun.
It's been really interesting because I'm getting to talk to all these experts
again,
getting to talk to all these like interesting,
intelligent people and crazy people too,
you know,
it's been like a couple of months so far,
a couple of weeks around there and a couple of weeks.
I've had so much fun.
Man.
I believe that 100 percent in the simulation theory it's getting worse and worse
and worse.
Why do you say that?
Like last night my,
I've been having problems with my website,
so I call a dream house who's my,
who serves it and it's like five in the morning and this girl lives in
California.
She works from her house and she's just helping me out and not to get your freak
on.
And it's kind of funny you said that.
So I,
uh,
I uh,
was watching this movie,
uh,
Tim and Eric's billion dollar movie and letting a Taffeta no one's got time for
that in the movie.
They were in this mall and it's,
I always find like places that have closed down,
interesting.
Like this whole mall is actually a real model that's in palm springs and
whatever.
So I'm like researching this mall while I'm on hold trying to get to talk to
this girl.
And uh,
I found out there was all these pictures of this big Marilyn Monroe statute
where they took two parts of Marilyn Monroe and put it in front of this mall and
somehow it came up with Google search and I'm just looking at this crazy
Maryland moreau thing.
Uh,
and then,
so I'm talking to this girl and uh,
the next day today I noticed that she follows me on twitter or somebody from
dreamhost follows me on twitter and who's a girl?
And she like writes me,
she's like,
you got somebody on your side,
I'm helping you out right now and I'm checking in that may try to help your
website.
Right?
So direct message.
So I go through her photos because see what she looks like.
One,
she's a pretty Asia and I'm like,
wow.
So you've started her after she was falling.
So I went through and I'm like,
wow,
she's a pretty Asian girl.
Like the fourth photo is her in front of that fucking Maryland Mary Statue.
Never seen in my whole entire life.
And now this girl that's helping me out,
this Asian girl that's helping me out.
Andrea,
you guys get him therapy together in the next picture.
If you backed up one further,
you'd see her finger yourself with the desk while the whole time.
I hope so.
This whole time that she's actually the one that hacked my computer.
Have you seen the pictures of Rhonda Rousy
with a desk while?
T shirt on the fucking coolest thing ever.
And that's very cool.
Seeing Ronda Rousey gives the thumbs up.
The baddest chick on the planet.
Yeah.
But by the way,
there's a lot of bad ass chicks on a planet.
There's a gang of a man,
there's some skillful women out there,
there.
So many of them.
This new fight that they have the new episode of the ultimate fighter with this
girl cat Zingano and Ronda Rousey together.
Uh,
looking at it.
That's awesome.
So nice man.
She wants to come on the podcast again too.
It's just going to be on somewhere after the beginning of May.
We're going to look how bad ass she is.
She has a fucking bed in her kitchen.
That's the way to do it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
she probably lives in a studio.
I mean she,
this is probably the same place.
She's one of those tricks that probably wants to keep it real too,
I think.
Well,
I don't want to say where she lives,
but she's awesome.
She'll be back here again,
but she's fighting a cat Zingano and they're going to coach against each other
on the ultimate fighter.
And a cat Zingano just beat Miesha tate.
Who's another beautiful dangerous girl.
And Cat Zingano too.
They're all like pretty girls that can beat the fuck out of you.
It's really kind of scary,
but this is in Gong.
Chick is I based man.
She's so bad ass.
She sure and Misha tate fought and cheat this combination that she finished her
with.
Dude,
pull it up.
Cat Zingano versus Misha tate.
The,
the,
the female fight.
Dude.
I was watching it and my friend [inaudible] place,
the female fight was the highlight of the room.
We were going crazy.
It was me,
my friend Aubrey and a bunch of his buddies,
he had like five of his friends over and we were eating Mexican food and
watching the fights.
Having a great fucking time,
but the room went nuts when the meesha take cuts and in.
Oh,
fight was going down.
It was chaos.
These girls were going off on each other.
Dude,
it's seriously.
Might've been one of the most entertaining fights I've ever seen in my life is
awesome.
You got to see the finished.
Just look up the finish.
The whole fight was great and you know me should take him really close again or
in a heel hook.
It was like dominant grappling exchanges and yeah,
you don't want to watch all this stuff now,
although the actual fight parts that are cut off youtube,
but I think they have like highlights.
Oh yeah.
These,
this is sort of showing you the highlight
was working.
You don't have to play all this stuff because I hope it doesn't get us
hold off of youtube or something like that,
but I probably won't.
I mean,
I know.
Imagine it just do picture in picture and you just show the video.
Yeah,
she beats.
They beat the fuck out of each other,
man.
It was nasty.
I mean it was like such a tightly,
tightly contested fight and really Misha tate was probably getting the better of
it on the scorecards,
but the end of it hits her with that elbow and drops her and referee Kim winslow
stops the fight.
She's a bad ass man.
Do you remember that?
Was like,
this is what excites me is it's not that the girls anymore,
it's now they're like really highly skilled fighters.
Yeah.
That not just women.
You know.
It's not just like,
hey,
girls can do it too.
It's like,
no,
these chicks are bad ass,
like they're not half fascinated.
They're all going for it.
Sure.
And now that Ronda Rousey's become so famous,
it's like this is going to open the door to so many female athletes that have
never even considered it before.
You started looking at it and you go,
you know what?
I was wanting to kick a bitches ass
rap.
I'm on.
It's going to happen.
Yeah.
A show starts in 15 minutes.
Just Siena.
Indeed it does,
Brian,
and we would know much better if you had a fucking clock that was more accurate.
Oh,
silly bitch.
How dare you?
Silly Bitch.
I'm powerful.
Kittycat clock.
Tommy Sigora.
Yo,
you're the champ.
Thanks Randy.
One of the greatest humans on the planet.
And thanks.
Bye Sweetheart.
To Buddy.
Uh,
I'm honored to be a friend.
Me Too,
man.
You guys are the best.
I love coming on your show.
It's a lot of fun.
While we love you too as well,
my friend and uh,
together we are stronger.
We are,
we're like,
um,
Genghis Khan would take one arrow.
Okay.
And you bring it in front of Truth and snap.
It may take a bundle of arrows and he couldn't snap it.
Yeah.
Just to let the troops know together we are stronger together.
We are strong,
but divided we are weak.
That's true.
And I know we talked about,
I talked about this with you and I talked about it with Christina a lot.
It was such a cool thing to have all of you like just as friends come out and do
our,
our fundraiser for the dog.
It was just such a cool feeling for us to be like,
have all this support of like you guys as friends just wanting to do it.
And then the crowd that night was just,
you know,
they were magic.
They're magic guys.
Man.
It was awesome,
man.
We couldn't.
I couldn't love you anymore than I do.
You're awesome.
I really appreciate.
We really appreciate it and we appreciate you too man.
You know,
look,
we're all lucky.
We're all lucky bitches.
We're all lucky that we know each other.
And uh,
we got a good group of evil.
We're going to keep this party rolling freaks.
There was no commercial coming in.
There's none coming out.
Sockets.
Halachic boy,
Paula Jihadi.
Hi Krishna.
God bless Duncan trussell.
We love the fuck out of you all.
We all are one together.
One for all.
Something like Robin Hood said,
piece to the guy or girl.com.
We love the shit out of you guys.
We'll see you Monday with Amy Schumer.
Amy Schumer
see Ya.
Love Ya.